PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE MEETING.
MEMBER TO SHOW UP SO WE CAN
ESTABLISH A QUORUM SO WE CAN OF
VISUALLY ESTABLISH.
THE COMMITTEE WITH ITS RULES SO
IF YOU JUST BEAR WITH US JUST A
LITTLE LONGER I BELIEVE THE RAIN.
CAN HELP PEOPLE UP --
AREA.
WE CAN BEGIN.
THE CALL THE COMMITTEE TO ORDER.
WILL ESTABLISH A QUORUM AT THE
COMMITTEE MADAM SECRETARY.
JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY [inaudible]
BARRICADE HAND [inaudible]
DEEP [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
QUIRK HERE SANTIAGO [inaudible]
SIX WARM IS PRESENT UP FIRST
THIS IS THE FIRST HEARING OF THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC
SAFETY.
A LET US BEGIN WITH SOME
HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS FIRST WE HAVE
THE COMMITTEE RULES.
IS THERE A MOTION TO MOVE THE
RULES THEIR SECOND [inaudible]
THE JONES SAWYER.
YES JOHN SIR I LACKEY.
BARRICADE HAN HI BAUER-KAHAN I
DEEP.
DEEP I KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE AYE QUIRK.
QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO [inaudible]
WICKS.
THE RULES ARE ADOPTED.
NEXT WE HAVE THE PROPOSED
CONSENT CALENDAR WE HAVE THE
FOLLOWING ITEMS ON CONSENT --
ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB --
ONE TWO SEVEN DRIVING UNDER THE
INFLUENCE IS URGENCY BECAUSE AB.
ONE SIX NINE LACKEY GUIDES
SIGNAL AND SERVICE DOGS INJURY
OR DEATH --
NUMBER NINE AB EIGHT ONE EIGHT
NINE COM LONGER DOVE CHILD ABUSE
OR NEGLECT MANDATED REPORTERS
AUTISM SERVICE PERSONNEL.
ITEM NUMBER TEN AB TWO ONE FIVE
MATHIS DUMPING.
IS THERE A MOTION --
MOVE THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
IS OUR SECOND.
MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL JONES SAWYER.
HI JOHN SIR I LACKEY.
BAUER-KAHAN BARRICADE HAND I
DEEP.
DEEP I KAMLAGER-DOVE OF
KAMLAGER-DOVE AYE QUIRK AYE
QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO [inaudible]
WICKS.
THE CONSENT CALENDAR HAS BEEN
DEDUCTED NOW TO OUR REGULAR
ORDER OF BUSINESS.
AND MR STONE YOU ARE OUR FIRST
[inaudible]
MEMBER.
ITEM NUMBER.
TWO OUR AB FORTY FIVE INMATE
MEDICAL CARE THESE.
THANKYOU MISTER CHAIR IS MY
WITNESSES COME FORWARD ME.
START SO LAST YEAR WITH THE HELP
OF YOUR COMMITTEE WE WERE TRYING
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
REDEFINING INDIGENT.
INMATES SO THAT THEY WOULD HAVE
ACCESS TO MEDICAL CARE TO THE
INCIDENTAL SAID THEY HAD AND
THROUGH THAT DISCUSSION WE
DISCOVERED.
THAT.
MANY COUNTY JAILS AND THEN THE
STATE WERE REQUIRING COPAYS AND
CO PAYS AS IT TURNS OUT FOR
MEDICAL.
DENTAL AND OTHER TREATMENTS ARE
REAL IMPEDIMENT TO GETTING
ACCESS TO THE SERVICES THAT THE
INMATES NEED.
NOW I KNOW.
MOST OF US ARE USED TO DEALING
WITH COPAYS AND IN OUR WORLD CO
PAYS PROVIDE.
INCENTIVES TO SHOW UP AND AND
AND HOW THEY HAVE A POTENTIAL
DESIRED EFFECT SO THAT WE ARE A
PART OF OUR MEDICAL TREATMENT
IT DOES NOT WORK THAT WAY IN
JAILS AND PRISONS AND IN FACT
THE RESEARCH SHOWS THAT IT THAT
THE CO.
ARE SIGNIFICANT IMPEDIMENT TO TO
GETTING SERVICES THERE WAS A
MERCED OUTBREAK.
IN CALIFORNIA PRISONS THAT WAS
TIED BACK TO THE FACT THAT
COPAYS WERE REQUIRED WERE A
AND INMATES THAT AND HAD TO MAKE
DECISION GETTING TREATMENT
WHETHER THEY COULD AFFORD TO GET
THE TREATMENT.
THE CENTER FOR DISEASE CONTROL
SHOWED THAT ARE TIED THAT THOSE
MERCS OUTBREAKS IN CALIFORNIA
GEORGIA AND TEXAS PRESENTS TO
THE THE FACT OF COPAYS.
AND THEN AGAIN THE THE OTHER
RESEARCH HAS IS REALLY POINTED
TO THE FACT THAT COMPANIES DON'T
WORK THE SAME WAY THAT THEY HAVE.
THAT WE'VE BEEN WORKING VERY
CLOSELY DID NOT ADD THIS TO LAST
YEAR'S BILL BECAUSE WE WANTED TO
WORK WITH THE DEPARTMENT ON THIS
ISSUE AND I HAVE TO SAY IT'S
BEEN.
A REAL PLEASURE WORKING WITH
THEM OVER THE LAST OVER THE FALL
AND THE EARLY PART OF THIS YEAR.
IN FACT THE CDC ARE HAS JUST
ISSUED.
GUIDANCE INTERNALLY SO THAT THEY
ARE GOING TO STOP.
IT --
REQUIRED COPAYS OF THEIR
PRISONERS AS OF MARCH.
ONE THIS BILL HOWEVER STILL
IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT REMOVES THE
STATUTORY AUTHORIZATION TO THEN
REINSTATE THOSE COPAYS AND WE'RE
GOING TO GO FURTHER AND WE'VE
BEEN TRYING TO TALK TO AS MANY
COUNTY JAILS AS WE CAN.
WE DON'T HAVE COMPLETE
INFORMATION ABOUT COUNTY JAILS
BUT A NUMBER OF THE ONES THAT WE
HAVE TALKED.
TO EITHER DON'T CHARGE COPAYS
BECAUSE THE ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS
FOR EXCEED WHAT THEY RECEIVE IN
THE COPAYS.
OR ARE MAKING DECISION NOW TO TO
STOP CAUSING TO SIDE ASKING FOR
THOSE COPAYS BECAUSE OF THE
IMPEDIMENTS THAT THEY KNOW THAT
THEY PROVIDE.
THAT'S THE BILL THIS BEFORE USED
TO REMOVE STATUTORY
AUTHORIZATION FOR COPAYS BOTH
FOR STATE PRISONS AND FOR LOCAL
JAILS AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
AND I DO HAVE WITNESSES. TO
EXPLAIN A LITTLE BIT ABOUT HOW
THEY WORK FOR BOTH YOU WITNESSES
YET YOU HAVE FIVE MINUTES TOTAL.
YOU CAN SPLIT IT UP ANY WAY YOU
WAT TO MINISTER PEACE.
BUT THE FIRST PERSON IF YOU GO
FOUR MINUTES AND THIRTY SECONDS
THAT MEANS.
THE NEXT ONE SO ONLY HAS THIRTY
SECONDS SO PLEASE BE COURTEOUS
TO THE SECOND SPEAKER.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS TYLER
LIGHTS ON I AM A COMMUNITY
ORGANIZER WHAT CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR WOMEN'S PRISONERS
AND A NATIONALLY SELECT THE PEER
TO PEER FELLOW.
I AM ALSO FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
INFORMALLY INCARCERATED WE
BELIEVE HEALTHCARE IS A HUMAN
RIGHT CHARGING FEES FOR ANY
MEDICAL TREATMENT SO AND ALREADY
STRUGGLING POPULATION.
IS ON JUST ENOUGH SAFE SO MANY
TIMES I WAS FACED WITH THE
DECISION TO SEE A DOCTOR ARGUES
MY LIMITED FUNDS --
HYGIENE WE'RE ALL AWARE OF THE
HUGE HEALTH WITH WE ARE SUBJECT
AND PEOPLE TO BUY TEN I LOVE BY
DETAINING LOVE ONES FROM NEED A
MEDICAL SERVICES WHILE.
ARE WHAT THEY ARE CROWD WHY THEY
ARE CROWDED TOGETHER.
IN SUCH A CONFINED SPACE
SERIOUSLY OUR HAS AGREED TO
ELIMINATE COPAYS BUT DOES THAT
AND THIS DOES NOT BENEFIT PEOPLE
INSIDE COUNTY JAILS AND PUT IN
HIS BILL INTO LAW WOULD PREVENT
CDC ARE FROM CHECK TO THAT
POLICY BACK. TO CHARGE A CO PAYS
ON A LATER DATE MANY A CUSTOMER
TO PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA NEVER
RECEIVE PROPER MEDICAL IT'S IT'S
ALONG THE STREETS.
DUE TO LACK OF COVERAGE AND KERR
ALLOWING MEDICAL FEES ASIDE
JAILS AND PRISONS FURTHER
RESTRICTS THEM FROM NEEDED
MEDICAL AND DENTAL SERVICES I'VE
PERSONALLY EXPERIENCED THE
WITNESS HOW MUCH SICKER PEOPLE
GET IN JAIL.
WHEN THEY AVOID ASKING FOR
MEDICAL HELP BECAUSE THEY DON'T
HAVE THE MONEY OR DON'T WANT TO
BE A MORE DAY THE SERVICE
ASSOCIATION AS OPPOSED IN THIS
BECAUSE THEY ARE CONCERNED WITH
WHAT THEY CALL FRIVOLOUS MEDICAL
VISITS?
BUT WE SENATE CALIFORNIA AND
ACROSS THE COUNTRY WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN A CUSTOMER TO PEOPLE ARE
DENIED MEDICAL HELP BECAUSE OF
THIS BIG MAN PEOPLE DIE.
PLEASE DO NOT ALLOW THIS FALSE
IDEA ABOUT INCARCERATED
ELIMINATED CO PAY ON CHARGES FOR
MEDICAL EQUIPMENT AS GO FOR OUR
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY FOR ALL
OF US.
I HOPE YOU WILL SUPPORT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER STONE A. B..
FORTY FIVE THANK YOU.
VERY GOOD TWO MINUTES.
A PRACTICE --
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE TWENTY MY NAME IS SAVANNAH
O'NEILL AND I'M THE CAPACITY
BUILDING A COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
MANAGER AT HARM REDUCTION
COALITION.
I'M HERE TODAY TO SHOW MY
ORGANIZATION STRONG SUPPORT FOR
A BI.
FORTY FIVE HERMAN ACTION
COALITION IS A NATIONAL ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION THAT PROMOTES THE
HEALTH AND DIGNITY OF
INDIVIDUALS AND COMMUNITIES
IMPACTED BY DRUG USE AND
RACIALIZED DRUG POLICY.
WITH EXTENSIVE WORK IN
CALIFORNIA WE SEE THE OVER A
PRESENTATION OF PEOPLE WHO USE
DRUGS AND PEOPLE OF COLOR INSIDE
CALIFORNIA'S CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM.
PART OF MY ROLE HERMAN ACTION
COALITION I WORKED AT CALIFORNIA
FORENSIC MEDICAL GROUP AT
SCENERY TO JAIL AND ALAMEDA
COUNTY.
I WORKED AS THE OPIATE TREATMENT
PROGRAM COORDINATOR WHERE I
PROVIDED COUNSELING AND SUPPORT
TO PATIENTS INSIDE THE CLINIC.
BUT UNLIKE OTHER PROVIDERS
PATIENTS DID NOT HAVE COPAYS TO
SEE ME.
I ANTICIPATE THE OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL WILL SUGGEST THAT
WITHOUT COPAYS TO DISCOURAGE
FRIVOLOUS MEDICAL VISITS
PATIENTS WILL OVERWHELM THE
SYSTEM FOR UNNECESSARY REASONS.
IN MY EXPERIENCE AS A PROVIDER
THIS WAS NOT TRUE PEOPLE CAME TO
SEE ME APPROPRIATELY AND WHEN
NEEDED AND YET WERE OFTEN NOT
SEEKING OTHER MEDICAL CARE DUE
TO COST.
DURING THE YEAR I WORKED IN
GENERATED JAIL AND THAT WITH
MANY PATIENTS WHO TOLD ME ABOUT
THEIR MISSING EYE GLASSES CHEST
PAINS SHOWED ME WOUNDS AND
PROTRUDING BONES.
MANY OF THESE PEOPLE STATED THEY
COULDN'T AFFORD TO REQUEST A HE
COULDN'T WRITE LETTERS TO HIS
DAUGHTER AND ANOTHER WOMAN SAID
SHE NEEDED TO SAVE EXTRA MONEY
FOR FOOD DURING HER PREGNANCY.
THIS COST LEADS PEOPLE TO MAKE
THE DIFFICULT CHOICE BETWEEN
MEDICAL CARE OR BASIC
NECESSITIES.
EVEN IN THE SHORT TIME I WITNESS
HEALTH CONDITIONS WORSENED BY
PEOPLE'S INABILITY TO ACCESS
CARE SOMETIMES LEADING THE
HOSPITALIZATIONS AND SURGERY.
LAST WEEK CDC ARE ANNOUNCED THEY
WILL ABOLISH COPAYS AFTER COMING
TO A SIMILAR CONCLUSION THEIR
PRESS RELEASE STATED IT WAS
DETERMINED THAT COPAYS HAVE
MINIMAL FISCAL BENEFITS AND ARE
NOT ALIGNED WITH PATIENT CARE.
YET THE SEVENTY THOUSAND HUMAN
BEINGS INSIDE CALIFORNIA JAILS
WILL NOT BENEFIT FROM THIS
CHANGE.
COPAYS AND JAILS LIKE SANTA RITA
WILL MAIN THREE DOLLARS A VISIT
AND WHILE THAT MIGHT SEEM LIKE A
SMALL AMOUNT IT CAN BE A LOT FOR
SOMEONE WHO'S INCARCERATED WHILE
IN JAIL PEOPLE HAVE NO ACCESS TO
ANY INCOME OR WORK UNLIKE THE
MINIMAL WORK AVAILABLE INSIDE
PRISONS.
AND PEOPLE IN JAIL FACE
ADDITIONAL FINANCIAL PRESSURES
IN LEGAL AND BILL FEES.
OVER MY TWELVE YEAR CAREER AS A
SOCIAL WORKER AND ADDICTION
TREATMENT COUNSELOR I'VE SEEN
HOW BARRIERS TO CARE OUTSIDE AND
INSIDE JAIL WALLS LEAD TO WORSE
MORE COMPLEX AND MORE EXPENSIVE
HEALTH ISSUES.
BY ELIMINATING THIS COPAY AB
FORTY FIVE WILL HELP IMPROVE
PUBLIC HEALTH AND BRING
CALIFORNIA ONE STEP CLOSER TO
CREATING MORE JUST HEALTH CARE
FOR PEOPLE BEHIND BARS.
I RESPECTFULLY URGE YOU TO VOTE
YES ON THIS IMPORTANT BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU LESS THAN FIVE
MINUTES EXCELLENT --
EITHER.
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT NAME AN
ORGANIZATION BECAUSE I SEE A
CHEN FLOOR IN BEHALF OF WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
VERY GOOD NAME AN ORGANIZATION
NECKS.
GOOD MORNING MARGOT GEORGE FOR
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LIZZY BEACON WITH THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA CO SPONSOR AND
SUPPORT.
Q..
YES MEAN PELLET WITH HELP ACCESS
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT.
YOU.
EMILY HARRIS OF ELLA BAKER
CENTER CO SPONSOR IN STRONG
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANDERSON WITH INITIATE JUSTICE
PROUD CO SPONSOR AND SUPPORT.
CALL BE LENDS WITH EASY TO BE P.
ANSWER I'VE BEEN PUNISHED
WORKING WITH INCARCERATED
MASSIVE VIOLENCE RUBBERS IN
SUPPORT.
GREG FIDO WITH INITIATE JESSA'S
PROUD CO SPONSOR IN SUPPORT.
MICHAEL MENDOZA WITH ANTI
RECIDIVISM OF COALITION SUPPORT.
ANDREW IN CHECK WILL STATE PRADA
REBOUND STRONGLY SUPPORT.
SHARON STONE WITH THE LEAGUE OF
WOMEN VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA AND
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
JIM LIMBURG FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION TO CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU [inaudible]
OUR EDDIE HAD CALIFORNIA CIVIL
LIBERTIES ADVOCACY AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESS IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible] TWENTY MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
COR CELLS A LOW HERE ON BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION --
WE ARE HERE IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL UNFORTUNATELY BUT TO BE
CLEAR SURE SIR ACUTELY AWARE OF
THE MEDICAL NEEDS OF INMATES IN
THEIR CARE AND CUSTODY.
STRIVE TO PROVIDE THEM WITH
APPROPRIATE TREATMENT THAT SAID
ELIMINATING THE ABILITY TO
CHARGE THIS MODEST FEE --
WHICH IS STATUTORILY IN WITH
LIMITED TO THREE DOLLARS WILL
REMOVE A USEFUL TOOL THAT
DISCOURAGES --
FRIVOLOUS REQUESTS FOR MEDICAL
VISITS WILL LET ME BE CLEAR THAT
STATUTE ALREADY PROVIDES.
BETTER IF NO FUNDS ARE AVAILABLE
IN A PERSON'S ACCOUNTS THERE IS
NO CHARGE FOR AN INMATE
INITIATED MEDICAL THIS.
BUT NO IN MADE SHALL BE DENIED
MEDICAL CARE BECAUSE OF A LACK
OF FUNDS IN THEIR PERSONAL
ACCOUNT.
THE STATUTE FURTHER PROVIDES AT
THE MEDICAL PROVIDER IS
PERMITTED TO WAIVE THE FEE IN
ANY CIRCUMSTANCE.
AND THAT THE MEDICAL PROVIDER
SHALL WAIVE THE FEE IN ANY
CIRCUMSTANCE FOR RELATING TO AN
EMERGENCY SITUATION OR ANOTHER
MEDICAL SITUATION INVOLVING
GREAT PAINTER IMMEDIACY.
AND FINALLY THE STATUTE ALREADY
PROVIDE AT THE DIRECTION OF
MEDICAL STAFF SHALL BE WITHOUT
CHARGE.
SO AGAIN THIS IS NOT ABOUT
TRYING TO COLLECT THREE DOLLARS
FROM AN INMATE JUST TO RAISE
MONEY THE THE CHALLENGE HERE IS
THAT.
THERE ARE INMATES. FOR BETTER OR
WORSE WHO SEEK MEDICAL ATTENTION
WHO SEEK TO GET OUT OF THERE SO --
BECAUSE NOT BECAUSE THEY HAD A
MEDICAL ISSUE NECESSARILY BUT
BECAUSE THEY THEY WANT TO LEAVE
THEIR CELL.
AND SO BECAUSE WE THINK THIS IS
A USEFUL TOOL IN PREVENTING OR
AT LEAST TRYING TO DISCOURAGE
THAT TYPE OF BEHAVIOR.
THAT DOES NOT HAVE THE IMPACT OF
STOPPING SOMEONE FROM GETTING
MEDICAL CARE IF THEY TRULY
NEEDED.
EVEN IF THEY DON'T HAVE ANY
FUNDS IN THERE AND MADE ACCOUNT --
FOR THOSE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED THE BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU. ONE MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS RANCHERO WITH THE
RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION
LIKE TO ECHO OF COMMENTS FROM
OUR COLLEAGUE --
SIR CELL SOLO AND ALSO REMIND
THE COMMITTEE THAT COUNTY JAIL
THROUGHOUT THE STATE ARE
COMPLETELY.
UNDERSTAFFED AN OVERCROWDED AND
HAVING -- A
MANDATE TO NOW WALK EVERY SINGLE
INMATE WHO REQUESTS MEDICAL --
IN FROM MEDICAL IS GOING TO
DEFINITELY IMPACT THE OPERATIONS
OF THE COUNTY JAILS.
AND FOR THOSE REASONS WERE
OPPOSED TO THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
IN.
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS FROM YES
MISTER.
SO MR CELLS ELLA --
MY CONCERN IS SOMEONE COULD HAVE
THREE DOLLARS IN AN ACCOUNT.
BUT IT'S THEIR ONLY THREE
DOLLARS AND THEY MIGHT NEEDED TO
MAKE A PHONE CALL HOME THAT
MIGHT NEEDED --
FOR OTHER PURPOSES AND SO EVEN
THOUGH THEY MIGHT HAVE THE THREE
DOLLARS GIVEN THAT THEY CAN'T
EARN MONEY WHILE THEY'RE IN JAIL.
AND MANY OF THEM ARE ISOLATED --
FROM FAMILY AND FRIENDS WHO
MIGHT BE ABLE TO GIVE THE MONEY --
AND I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT'S
ALLOW THEIR THAT THAT'S MY MAIN
CONCERN WITH THIS NOT THAT.
I AM SURE THAT THE SHERIFF IS I
KNOW HIM IN ALAMEDA COUNTY
ASSEMBLY DIDN'T HAVE THREE
DOLLARS HE LET HIM GO --
BUT MY CONCERN IS THAT THEY HAVE
SO LITTLE MONEY THAT THREE
DOLLARS IS VERY PRECIOUS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS SO.
THAT'S MY CONCERN YOU HAVE A
RESPONSE OH SURE I DON'T.
KNOW IF THE QUESTION.
IS WHETHER THE CHAIR OF THE I
TOTALLY UNDERSTAND MISTER QUIRK
AND I I THINK IN THE SITUATION
WHICH YOU DESCRIBED IN WHICH AN
INMATE DOESN'T HAVE.
SUFFICIENT FUNDS IN THE ACCOUNT
THE STATUTE IRRESPECTIVE OF THE
SHERIFF DECISION THE STATUTE
PROVIDES.
THAT THE PERSON SHALL NOT BE
CHARGED IF THEY DON'T HAVE
REALLY RECOGNIZES.
THAT CONCERN IN THAT WAY AND WE
THINK DISTRICTS THE APPROPRIATE
BALANCE BETWEEN SAYING LOOK IF A
PERSON IS MEDICAL CARE AND THEY
DON'T HAVE THE FUNDS.
THEN THAT'S THE SITUATION BUT
THERE ARE OTHER WAYS TO GET
FUNDS IN THE ACCOUNT IF THERE
ARE FAMILY UNDERSTAND YOUR
EXAMPLE TALK ABOUT SOMEONE WHO
MAY BE ISOLATED.
BUT IF THEY HAVE SOME FUNDS IN
THE ACCOUNT AND THAT'S
DETERMINATION THAT NEEDS TO BE
MADE AGAIN.
THE PROVIDER IS PERMITTED TO
WAIVE THE FEE AND IF THERE'S
ANYTHING THAT'S AN ACTUAL
EMERGENCY THEY'RE REQUIRED TO
WAIVE THE FEE.
BUT THE POINT HERE IS --
YOU KNOW YOU COULD HAVE.
A BAD COLD BIKE I HAVE HAD FOR
THE LAST MONTH THAT COULD BE
GOING INTO BRONCHITIS.
IT'S NOT AN EMERGENCY BUT YOU
ONLY HAVE THREE DOLLARS IN YOUR
ACCOUNT AND YOU REALLY WANT TO
MAKE THAT CALL OUR AND YOU NEED
THAT THREE DOLLARS TO MAKE THAT
CALL --
SOMEONE.
WOULD BE TEMPTED PERHAPS NOT TO
GO AND THEN THEY HAVE PNEUMONIA --
BEFORE SO MY QUESTION AGAIN IF
THEY DON'T HAVE THE THREE
DOLLARS IT'S CLEAR BUT IF THEY
ONLY HAVE THREE DOLLARS MY
CONCERN IS.
THAT THEY WOULD BE TEMPTED NOT
TO GO WORSE IN MY YOU KNOW.
DO YOU HAVE A SOLUTION FOR THIS
PROBLEM.
BY.
THE THE CASE IN WHICH YOU
DESCRIBE COULD BE FAIRLY
SPECIFIC AND AS MUCH AS AN
INMATE MAY ONLY HAVE EXACTLY THE
PRICE OF THE MEDICAL COPAY.
THIS ASSUMING THAT THE SHERIFF
IS ACTUALLY CHARGING AT AND IF
THEY'RE IN A SITUATION WHERE THE
FEES CHARGED.
AND THE PERSON ONLY HAS EXACTLY
THREE DOLLARS AND THEY HAVE TO
MAKE THAT CHOICE AND THAT'S A
CHOICE THAT HAS TO BE MADE AND
HOPEFULLY THEY'LL CHOOSE THE
MEDICAL CARE BUT WE UNDERSTAND.
THE CONCERN BUT THAT'S AGAIN WE
WE WE SEE THE THE THE THE BIGGER
CONCERN FOR US IS THAT WHEN
SOMEONE WHO IS NOT IN NEED OF
MEDICAL CARE --
THAT AGAIN THIS CAN BE A
DETERRENT TO SEEKING WHAT WE
WOULD DESCRIBE AS A FRIVOLOUS
REQUEST.
MOVE THE BILL [inaudible]
YES.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER STONE DID I
UNDERSTAND YOU CORRECTLY THAT
CDC OURS ALREADY REMOVED THIS
PRACTICE YES THEY HAVE AND IN
FACT THERE ARE A NUMBER OF THE
WE DON'T HAVE COMPLETE
INFORMATION WE WE'VE BEEN TRYING
TO REACH OUT TO ALL THE COUNTIES.
AND HEARD BACK FROM ONLY SOME
BUT COUNTIES FOR EXAMPLE AS
LARGE AS SANTA CLARA.
DON'T CHARGE THESE HE'S ALREADY
BECAUSE THE COST OF THE
ADMINISTRATION IS MORE THAN WHAT
THEY RECEIVE.
THEY OBVIOUSLY HAVE NOT FOUND A
CHALLENGE WITH FRIVOLOUS.
SUITS AND THE RESEARCH HAS BEEN
DONE NATIONALLY --
BOTH STATE JAILS AND LOCAL JAILS
AND STATE PRISONS.
HAS SHOWN THAT THESE KINDS OF
FEES THE COPAYS ARE MORE OF AN
IMPEDIMENT TO GETTING.
ACCESS SO THAT SOMEONE WHO HAS.
MINIMAL AMOUNTS IN THEIR CAMP
MAY NOT SEEK SERVICE BECAUSE
THEY THEY WANT TO HOLD ON TO
THAT MONEY AND YES THE SHERIFF'S
OFFICE MAY HAVE THE RIGHT OR THE
ABILITY TO WAY THAT.
BUT IF THEY DON'T THEN THAT IN
SAID THAT IN MAY TENDS NOT TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE MEDICAL
SERVICES.
THEREBY FORCING A AN EMERGENCY
SITUATION WHERE THERE HAD BEEN
ONE IN THE PAST.
THIS IS A POPULATION THAT HAS
VERY LOW HEALTH EDUCATION THEY
DON'T ALWAYS UNDERSTAND HOW THE
SYSTEMS WORK SO THEY'RE NOT
INCLINED TO WANT TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF IT WHICH IS WHY
THIS BILL IS BEING SUPPORTED.
BY A NUMBER THE MEDICAL HEALTH
PROVIDERS BECAUSE THEY SEE ON A
DAY TO DAY BASIS IN JAILS AND
PRISONS.
THAT DID AREA THAT THIS
REPRESENTS.
YES MISS KAMLAGER-DOVE MISTER
STONE THANK YOU SO I HAVE ALSO
READ THAT IF A PERSON IS UNABLE
TO PAY THE THREE DOLLARS AT A
HOLD IS PUT ON THEIR ACCOUNT FOR
THIRTY DAYS.
AND SO WITH THIS BILL REMOVE
THAT WHOLE CAN YOU SPEAK TO THAT
IT WOULD TAKE AWAY THE STATUTORY.
AUTHORITY TO CHARGE THE COPAY SO
THERE COULD BE NO ACTION TAKEN
AGAINST IT AND MADE WITH RESPECT
TO HOW MUCH THEY HAVE OR DON'T
HAVE IN THEIR ACCOUNT.
BECAUSE THERE WOULD BE NO
AUTHORIZATION TO CHARGE THAT
COPAYS WOULD NOT BE OWED FROM
THAT THAT INMATE AT ALL.
YOU WOULD HAVE TO DEAL WITH --
ACT.
HI SECOND DOCTOR QUICK MOTION
MOVED ABOUT.
ALL RIGHT BE MORE QUESTIONS.
YOU MAY CLOSE I ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU [inaudible]
VIEW -- SO --
IS IS IRONIC WE'RE HAVING.
THE DISCUSSION ABOUT PAYING FOR
MEDICAL CARE INSIDE OF JAILS
WERE HAVING THE SAME
CONVERSATION WITH A FOUR WHEEL
CARE ACT IN.
HEALTH CARE FOR ALL WERE WERE
TRYING TO GET TO A POINT.
WE DON'T PAY.
OR FIVE THE SYSTEM WHERE.
IS AFFORDABLE FOR EVERYONE.
AND I KNOW THREE DOLLARS. FOR
THOSE OF YOU MAY NOT KNOW MAIN
NOT SEEM LIKE A LOT OF MONEY BUT
IT'S A LOT OF MONEY WHEN YOU'RE.
WHEN YOU'RE IN JAIL?
ONE AND TWO I I THINK THE PEOPLE
WHO DO HAVE TE CAPACITY TO HAVE
THE THREE DOLLARS MAY STILL.
DO TO FRIVOLOUS TYPE OF THINGS
THAT THE SHERIFF DEPARTMENTS
TALKING ABOUT I'M AND WE SHOULD
BE -- ON
DEFINITELY --
COGNIZANT OF THAT THAT COULD
PRESENT SOME PROBLEMS BUT AT THE
END OF THE DAY AFTER WATCHING
SOMEONE LIKE MY COLLEAGUE.
MISTER QUIRK WHO THOUGHT HE JUST
HAD A MINOR COLD.
AND ALL OF A SUDDEN MISS THE TO
BRONCHITIS.
I CAN SEE HOW.
SOMEONE NOT MEDICALLY TRAINED
MAY DENY SOMEONE.
AS THEY NOW HAVE THE POWER
BECAUSE OF THREE DOLLARS WAS THE
LIMIT.
OR FIVE DOLLARS WHATEVER IS TO
DETER SOMEONE THEY NOW CAN JUST
SAY NO BECAUSE THEY DON'T THINK
YOUR BILL ENOUGH FOR WHATEVER.
ASIDE EIGHT CHAIRS RECOMMENDED I
VOTE AND MAY CALL THE ROLL.
ON AB FORTY FIVE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER AYE JONES
SAWYER AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY NO BARRICADE HAND.
BAUER-KAHAN I DEEP [inaudible]
THANK.
DEEP ABSTAINED KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE AYE QUIRK.
QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
WICKS I WICKS I THE MEASURE
PASSES THANK YOU AND THANK --
JESSE GABRIEL.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GABRIEL AB ONE
SIX FIVE ITEM NUMBER
[inaudible]
SEVEN YEAH.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TODAY.
TO PRESENT AB ONE SIXTY FIVE
THIS IS A BILL THAT WILL SAVE
LIVES BY ENSURING THAT OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS ARE
PROPERLY TRAINED.
ON THE USE OF GUN VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDERS.
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW I. G. V. R.
O. IS A JUDICIAL ORDER THAT
ALLOWS LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
TEMPORARILY CONFISCATE FIREARMS
FROM AN INDIVIDUAL.
WHO POSES AN IMMINENT RISK OF
HARM TO THEMSELVES OR OTHERS?
WHEN PROPERLY USED G. V. R. OWES
ARE A POWERFUL TOOL THAT CAN
PREVENT MASS STUDENT NOW
SHOOTINGS SUICIDES AND SAVE
LIVES?
UNFORTUNATELY GEV ARE ALWAYS
HAVE BEEN RELATIVELY UNDER
UTILIZED SINCE THEY WERE FIRST
INTRODUCED IN.
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN NOTABLY
LESS THAN TWO HUNDRED ORDERS
WERE ISSUED DURING THE FIRST TWO
YEARS THEY WERE AVAILABLE.
THOSE NUMBERS INCREASED SOMEWHAT
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THANKS
LARGELY TO INNOVATIVE TRAINING
PIONEERED BY DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
IN SEVERAL COUNTIES.
WHICH HAVE HELPED LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN THOSE
JURISDICTIONS BETTER UNDERSTAND
WHEN AND HOW TO SEEK THESE
ORDERS. FOR EXAMPLE A HUNDRED
EIGHTY FIVE G. V. R. O. S. WERE
ISSUED IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY LAST
YEAR 43% OF THE STATEWIDE TOTAL.
THANKS TO THE GOOD WORK OF SAN
DIEGO CITY ATTORNEY MARK ELLIOTT
WHO HAS BEEN A KEY ADVOCATE AND
LEADER FOR INCREASED TWO G. B.
R. O. TRAINING.
THESE STATISTICS SHOW US THE
TRAINING WORKS AND THAT WE NEED
STATEWIDE TRAINING TO ENSURE
THAT THIS POWERFUL TOOL IS BEING
USED TO ITS FULL POTENTIAL SO
THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT CAN PROTECT
THEMSELVES AND KEEP THE PUBLIC
SAFE.
WITH ME TODAY ARE TO TESTIFY ARE
TWO LEADING ADVOCATES JULIA
WEBER FROM THE DIFFERENCE
LAWCENTER AND AMANDA WILCOX FROM
THE BRADY CAMPAIGN TO PREVENT
GUN VIOLENCE.
YES THANK YOU THANK YOU --
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME
IS JULIE A WEBER AND I'M
APPEARING ON BEHALF OF GIFFORD'S
LAW CENTER TO PREVENT GUN
VIOLENCE.
IN SUPPORT AND AS A SPONSOR OF
AB.
ONE SIXTY FIVE I WORKED IN THE
FIELD OF DOMESTIC SPONSOR FOR
OVER TWENTY YEARS INCLUDING
SEVENTEEN YEARS WITH THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL DEVELOPING
RULES AND FORMS IN THE AREA OF
PROTECTIVE IN RESTRAINING ORDERS.
AND PROVIDING EDUCATION FOR THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH AND TEACHING
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE A GOLDEN GATE
UNIVERSITY SCHOOL OF LAW.
I'M NOW A FELLOW WITH THE
GIFFORDS LAWCENTER FOCUSED ON
GUN VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDER
IMPLEMENTATION STATEWIDE.
UNFORTUNATELY WE BELIEVE THIS
IMPORTANT TOOL HAS NOT BEEN
FULLY UTILIZED BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT OR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC.
IN PART BECAUSE OF LIMITED
TRAINING AND INFORMATION
DISSEMINATION ABOUT GUN VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDERS R. G. B. R.
ROSE.
THEY ARE DIFFERENT FROM OTHER
RESTRAINING ORDERS IN SEVERAL
WAYS OF FIRST WALL THE GT R. O.
IS A CIVIL MATTER CRIMINAL
PROCEEDING LAW ENFORCEMENT PLAYS
A SIGNIFICANT ROLE.
IN G. R. OWES ITS FUNDAMENTALLY
DIFFERENT FROM OTHER RESTRAINING
ORDERS AND OTHER PROCESS SEES.
THERE'S ENORMOUS POTENTIAL FOR
CONFUSION BETWEEN THE NOW TWO
DIFFERENT EMERGENCY PROTECTIVE
ORDERS WE NOW HAVE TWO DIFFERENT
E. P. O.'S. ONE FOR DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE CHILD ABUSE AND
STOCKING AND ONE FOR GUN
VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDERS.
ARE AND ALSO AFTER THE EMERGENCY
PROTECTIVE ORDER WERE LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS A PARTY IN THE
CASE WHICH IS DIFFERENT FROM
OTHER RESTRAINING ORDERS.
ADDITIONALLY THE G. V. R. O. IS
CIVIL BUT APPEARS IN THE PENAL
CODE.
WHICH HAS CAUSED SOME CONFUSION
FOR FOR ITS LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
OTHERS.
THE BASIS FOR AND REMEDIES UNDER
THE GB RO ARE MARKEDLY DIFFERENT
FROM OTHER RESTRAINING ORDERS.
OTHER RESTRAINING ORDERS ARE
GENERALLY DESIGNED TO PROTECT AN
INDIVIDUAL FROM DANGER BY
RESTRAINING ANOTHER PERSON'S
BEHAVIOR THE G. V. R. O.
RESTRAINED SOMEONE'S BEHAVIOR
BUT PROTECTS THE PUBLIC AT LARGE.
WE KNOW INFORMATION
DISSEMINATION TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
ANOTHER KEY STAKEHOLDERS HAS
BEEN LIMITED.
AND IN OTHER STATES GRASSROOTS
EFFORTS DESIGNED TO BUILD
SUPPORT FOR THE POLICY CHANGE
MEANT MORE STAKEHOLDERS KNEW
ABOUT THE LAW BEFORE IT WAS
ENACTED.
SO FINALLY I WOULD NOTE THAT
THERE ARE QUESTIONS ABOUT
WHETHER SOME RECENT TRAGEDIES
INVOLVING CALLS TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT MAY HAVE BEEN
PREVENTED HAD A G. V. R. O. BEEN
EXECUTED.
AND FIREARMS CONFISCATED UNDER
THE G. V. R. O..
TRAINING IS CRITICAL TO FULLY
REALIZE ALL OF THE G. V. R. O.
IN OUR STATE WE URGE YOU TO VOTE
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
A GOOD MORNING.
MY NAME IS AMANDA WILCOX I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTERS OF THE BRADY CAMPAIGN
TO PREVENT GUN VIOLENCE.
A FOR THE NEW MEMBERS HERE --
I'LL JUST LET YOU KNOW THAT I'VE
BEEN OF ADVOCATE AS A VOLUNTEER.
SINCE TWO FIVE TWO THOUSAND FIVE
IN THIS BUILDING.
AND I DO THIS WORK IN MEMORY OF
MY DAUGHTER WHO WAS KILLED IN
THE RAMPAGE SHOOTING IN JANUARY
TWO THOUSAND ONE IN NEVADA
COUNTY.
THE BRADY CAMPAIGN WAS
INSTRUMENTAL IN THE PASSAGE OF
THE ORIGINAL LAW AND TWENTY
FOURTEEN AYE AND WE WORKED VERY
HARD ON THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THAT LAW WHICH WENT INTO EFFECT
TWENTY SIXTEEN IN FACT WE WORK
BEFORE.
TWENTY SIXTEEN I WITH YOU JUST
JUDICIAL COUNCIL AS THEY WERE
SETTING UP THE PROCESS SOME
FORMS -- USE
OF THE LAW AS YOU'VE HEARD HAS
BEEN --
DISAPPOINTING AND SLOW I BELIEVE
STRONGLY BELIEVE THAT THIS LAW
HAS THE POTENTIAL TO SAVE MANY
LIVES IN THE FACT THAT IT HAS
BEEN SO UNDER USED IN CALIFORNIA.
IS CAUSE FOR CONCERN FOURTEEN
OTHER STATES HAVE NOW ENACTED
SIMILAR LAWS IN APPEARS THAT
MOST STATES ARE USING IT.
AT A FAR GREATER RATE THAN
CALIFORNIA WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
IT'S VERY CLEAR TO ME.
THAT SOME AGENCIES DO NOT EVEN
KNOW ABOUT THE LAW.
OTHERS DO NOT UNDERSTAND HOW IT
FILLS GAPS IN EXISTING LAW.
IN OUR MANY AGENCIES DO NOT HAVE
A PROCESS FOR IMPLEMENTING THE
LAW IN THEIR OWN JURISDICTION.
AM IN AS IF YOU'RE HURT IT'S IN
THE ANALYSIS IN THE MEMBER
STATED THAT A MANY COUNTIES.
HAVE NEVER HEARD AND ISSUED AN
ORDER THERE'S TWENTY MY OWN
COUNTY NEVADA COUNTY IS ISSUED.
ONE AND THEY DID IT AFTER I
HAPPEN TO TELL OUR DISTRICT
ATTORNEY WHO'S A FRIEND WHO WERE
IN A MEETING TOGETHER ABOUT THE
LAW.
THAT'S A HECK OF A WAY TO INFORM
HARM LAW ENFORCEMENT OF A NEW
LAW YOU KNOW THE CHANCES THAT A
ADVOCATES FRIENDS WITH SOMEONE
IN LAW ENFORCEMENT IN THE COUNTY --
SO WE REALLY NEED TO OUR STATE
WIDE PROCESS FOR EDUCATING --
LAW ENFORCEMENT AS WELL AS OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS BUT PARTICULARLY
LAW ENFORCEMENT WHO ARE USING
THE MOST THEY'VE USED IN 90% OF
THE TIME THUS FAR --
ON HOW TO USE THIS LOSS THAT WE
CAN REALIZE LIFESAVING BENEFITS.
MY DAUGHTER'S KILLER.
HAD THAT MENTAL ILLNESS BUT HE
HAD NEVER BEEN.
FIFTY ONE FIFTY I DID NOT HAVE A
SEVENTY TWO HOUR OR EXCUSE ME
DID NOT HAVE A FIVE YEAR MENTAL
HEALTH HOLD HE NEVER COMMITTED A
CRIME WE HEAR THAT STORY.
SO OFTEN HIS FAMILY MEMBERS HIS
GIRLFRIEND IS HANK'S WORKER ALL
CONCERNED ABOUT ON THERE IS NO
LEGAL TOOL AT THAT TIME FOR
REMOVING THE GUN.
I DO NOT WANT THAT SITUATION
HAPPEN AGAIN TO OTHER FAMILIES
PARTICULARLY WHEN WE HAVE A TOOL
WE JUST NEED TO USE THAT.
SIRE URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THIS
LEGISLATION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT NAME AN ORGANIZATION.
MISTER MEMBERS AT OKAY BUT ON
BEHALF OF EVERY TOWN FOR GUN
SAFETY AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS AN ATOMIC ON THE
LEADER OF THE YOLO COUNTY
CHAPTER OF MOMS DEMAND ACTION
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT AB ONE
SIXTY FIVE HE MARY LOU RESERVE --
ASSETTO FROM YOLO COUNTY MOMS
DEMAND ACTION FORMER POLICE
OFFICER.
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
ROSE MAY YOSHIKAWA I'M WITH US
SACRAMENTO MOMS DEMAND ACTION
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
THANK YOU.
CYNTHIA SHALLOT MEMBER OF MOMS
DEMAND ACTION FOR GUN SENSE IN
AMERICA I LIVE IN SACRAMENTO AND
I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
CALVIN QUICK BAY AREA STUDENT
ACTRESS STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
TIFFANY MATTHEWS ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
WORK SEVEN MOMS DEMAND ACTION
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SYLVIA
SOLELY SHAUN BEHALF OF LOS
ANGELES CITY ATTORNEY MIKE
FUEHRER AND THE CITY ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE CURRENTLY HOLDS TRAININGS
FOR ELLIE P. AND THEY ONLY
SCHOOL POLICE BUT WE STRONGLY
BELIEVE IN SYSTEMATIZING THE
TRAINING. TO ENHANCE PUBLIC
SAFETY ACROSS THE STATE THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
ARE A ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
A WITNESS IN OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS HAVE A COMMENT COMMENT
[inaudible]
MR LACKEY.
L. A RESUME OF GABRIEL YOU'RE TO
BE COMMENDED FOR RECOGNIZING
SOMETHING THAT'S A REALLY REALLY.
A NICE TOOL THAT NEEDS TO BE.
SPREAD AMONGST THE A LAW
ENFORCEMENT PROFESSION.
HOWEVER HERE'S MY CONCERN MY
CONCERN IS.
I'M CLEARLY GOING TO SUPPORT THE
BILL.
BUT I FEAR THAT THE COST MAY
BECOME PROBLEMATIC AND HERE'S
THE BIGGEST COST OF I THINK YOU
NEED TO REALLY.
THINK THROUGH OF MAYBE A MORE
PRACTICAL WAY THOSE WHO ARE
ALREADY IN THE FIELD WE HAVE A
HUNDRED SEVENTEEN THOUSAND PEACE
OFFICERS IN NINETEEN HUNDREDS OF
DECENT LIKE THAT.
IN CALIFORNIA AND TO TRAIN ALL
OF THEM WITHIN TWO YEARS IS A
VERY EXPENSIVE AND VERY
AGGRESSIVE.
GOAL I I'D SAY THE ENTRANCE
LEVEL BUT THAT COULD BE HANDLED.
WITH REASON WILL COST.
BUT KNOWING THE SYSTEM AND
KNOWING THE DEMANDS ON BUDGETS I
CAN TELL YOU THAT THAT IS.
GOING TO BE A REAL IMPEDIMENT.
AND IT'S SOMETHING THAT YOU
SHOULD CONSIDER VERY VERY --
SERIOUSLY SO --
NO THIS IS A GREAT TOOL AND I
CAN TELL YOU AFTER TWENTY YEARS
WILL ON FORCE A PROFESSION THAT
TRAINING.
GOOD TRAINING.
IS INVALUABLE AND IT IS THE WAY
TO SHAPE BEHAVIOR OF OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT SO THANK YOU FOR FOR
THIS -- VERY
IMPORTANT BILL.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ANY.
SO -- MISTER
VICE CHAIR YOU BRING UP A BIG
CONCERN AND WE HAVE BILLS EVERY
YEAR ASKING FOR THIS OR THAT
INTO POST.
ALL I WOULD SAY --
IN THIS CASE THIS IS ONE THAT I
CAN SUPPORT I NOTE THAT THAT
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
THE CALIFORNIA STATEWIDE LAW
ENFORCEMENT ASSOCIATION.
ARE IN FAVOR IN THERE ARE WELL
AWARE OF YOU ARE IN PARTICULAR
SO WITH THAT I'LL MOVE TO BAIL.
MS BAUER CON [inaudible]
OR YES YOU HAVE A QUESTION.
SO -- LOG
THOUGH THANK YOU BOTH FOR YOUR
COMMENTS I TO WILL BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL BUT I HAD A QUESTION.
MAYBE IT WAS BECAUSE I STEPPED
OUT DO WE KNOW WHAT THE COSTS
ARE THAT ARE SO --
SO SEATED WITH THE BILL.
I DON'T KNOW I I DON'T HAVE
SPECIFIC NUMBERS AND PERHAPS TO
DO BUT ON THE TRAIN ON THE
TRAINING WILL I WOULD JUST WANT.
TO THROW IN A COMMENT HERE THAT
WE ALREADY REQUIRE TRAINING ON
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE EMERGENCY
PROTECTIVE ORDERS AND PROCEDURES
FOR OF SERVING ORDERS AND ALSO
ON DE ESCALATION IN MENTAL
HEALTH SITUATIONS AND SO THE THE
FACT THAT WE MAY NOT BE ABLE TO
FULLY INTEGRATE THE G. V. R. O..
INFORMATION IS IS A PROBLEM FOR
ALL THAT EXISTING TRADING SO I
WOULD JUST.
SUPPORT THE IDEA THAT IT ONLY
MAKES SENSE TO INCLUDE G. B. R.
O. INFORMATION IN ANY TRAINING
ON OTHER RELATED ISSUES MENTAL
HEALTH SUICIDE PREVENTION AND
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
IN I WOULD NOTE THAT IN THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET OF
COURSE THAT'S NOT A SIGN BUDGET
YET THAT HE HAS INCREASED
SIGNIFICANTLY.
ARE THE FUNDS AVAILABLE TO POST
TO CREATE NEW UNITS --
HOPEFULLY ONE OF THESE NEW UNITS
THE G. VERO TRAINING AND I'VE
HAD DISCUSSIONS WITH POST
REGARDING THE TRAINING VIDEO
WHICH LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
OF ACTUALLY ASKED --
FOR AND THE COST OF TRAINING
VIDEO WHICH IS VERY TYPICAL FOR
SHOWING.
OFFICERS --
WHO ARE ALREADY SERVING IS ABOUT
A HUNDRED THIRTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN THE SCHEME OF THINGS
FOR CALIFORNIA THAT'S A VERY
SMALL AMOUNT OF MONEY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I CAN I IT YOU'RE JUST DOING
YOUR CALLS CRASH ONE THAT
RESPOND TO HIS COULD.
DO QUESTION [inaudible]
GO AHEAD.
A SECOND MISTER CLARK'S MOTION
OF THE BILL.
OKAY.
THE OTHER QUESTIONS JUST REAL
QUICKLY.
SECOND SHOT OF THE WELL THE BY
SHEER GET SPECIAL COMPENSATION
HERE'S MY BIGGEST CONCERN IS
THAT TWO YEAR REQUIREMENT RIGHT
BE GIVEN MORE TIME WHAT WOULD BE.
MORE MANAGEABLE AND AND LESS
MONEY.
BECAUSE YOU'RE OVER TIME
CONSIDERATIONS ALL THESE OTHER --
VERY VERY COSTLY CONSIDERATION
SO THAT'S WOULD YOU CONSIDER
EVEN.
EXTENDING THAT TO YOUR WENT ON
TO THE FIRST QUESTION AN EXACT
WONDERFUL THANK THANK OF OF DEEP
EXPERIENCE HERE AND I'M.
VERY VERY GRATEFUL FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THE SPELL --
ABSOLUTELY WE JUST RECEIVED A
LETTER FROM PORAC I JUST BECAME
AWARE OF IT --
YESTERDAY WHEN THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR TO TO US WE ARE VERY
EAGER TO BE IN CONVERSATIONS
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT TO DO THIS
IN A WAY WHERE EVERYBODY CAN BE
IN SUPPORT.
AND IN -- IN
A WAY THAT WE CAN ACHIEVE THE
GOALS OF THIS BILL WHICH I I
FIRMLY BELIEVE WILL HELP SAVE
LIVES BUT ALSO ARE SENSITIVE TO
THE NEEDS OF OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS THAT ARE GOING TO DO
THIS WORK IN THE FIELD SO
ABSOLUTELY.
THANK YOU.
THE OTHER QUESTIONS AND YOU MAKE
CLOTHES MISTER GABER I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU YES AND SO I I
JUST WANT TO REMIND EVERYBODY
AND IT'S GOOD TO ASK HOW MUCH
THINGS COST BUT THIS IS THE
POLICY.
COMMITTEE --
AND SINCE I SERVE ON BUDGET SO.
FIVE EVER SINCE I'VE BEEN HERE I
BOTH CHAIRED AND BEEN ON BUDGETS
OF FIVE ALL.
ALL THE YEARS I'VE BEEN IN THE
ASSEMBLY --
WE'LL TAKE A LOOK AT THE COSTS
SHOULD ALSO MENTION.
EVERY YEAR THIS BODY MONEY INTO
POST THE PREVIOUS GOVERNOR.
JUST SAY WAS TAKEN OUT.
AND WE PUSHED AND PUSHED AND
PUSHED HARPER FOR MONEY IN THE
POST AND TRAINING TO HIGH
PRIORITY FOR US --
I THINK A LOT OF BILLS EVEN GET
THROUGH APPROPRIATIONS --
STATE THEY FEEL THAT IT'S
SOMETHING THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE
SO I AM HOPING THAT AS THIS
MOVES FORWARD AND I'M
RECOMMENDED NIGHT IS MOVES
FORWARD --
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT THEY'LL GET
MONETIZED IN APPROPRIATIONS.
THAT --
IT'LL STILL MOVE FORWARD AFTER
THAT NICO MANAGER CALDERON.
ON AB ONE SIXTY FIVE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GABRIEL THE
MOTION IS TO PASSED YOU
APPROPRIATIONS JONES SAWYER CHEN
SO YOU'RE AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE BARRICADE HAND.
BAUER-KAHAN I DEEP.
DEEP I KAMLAGER-DOVE I
KAMLAGER-DOVE I QUIRK AYE QUIRK
AYE SANTIAGO.
WICKS HIGH SWIG SIGH.
THAT PASSES GRADUATION THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER.
THIS YOUR FIRST BILL.
OKAY MISTER COOPER A. B. ONE
THREE SEVEN UP.
PEACE OFFICER BILL OF RIGHTS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BURST
A BE ONE THREE SEVEN CREATES A
MINIMUM STANDARD.
THE TYPE OF INFORMATION AFFORD A
PEACE OFFICER IN NON CRIMINAL
ADMINISTRATIVE INVESTIGATIONS.
EXISTING LAW REQUIRES A PEACE
OFFICER MUST BE NOTIFIED OF THE
NATURE OF THE INVESTIGATION.
PRIOR TO INTERROGATION.
SOME EMPLOYERS HAVE NARROWLY
INTERPRETED THE NATURE
INVESTIGATION TO MEAN ONLY THE
DATE TIME AND PLACE OF THE
INTERROGATION.
AND SOMETIMES A CHARGE OF THE
THIS IS CREATE DELAYS IN THE NON
CRIMINAL ADMINISTRATIVE PROCESS
UNNECESSARILY STOLEN THAT'S
OCCASIONS AS WILL FILL GIVE
PEACE OFFICERS THE BASIC RIGHTS.
OF FAIR IN REPRESENTATION.
AB ONE THREE SEVEN SIX TO
MAINTAIN THE EMPLOYER EMPLOYEE
RELATIONSHIP BY PROVIDING PEACE
OFFICERS IN THEIR UNION
REPRESENTATIVES WITH THE MINIMUM
AMOUNT OF INFORMATION TO RESPOND
TO INVESTIGATIONS.
IN A TIMELY MANNER.
AB ONE THIRTY SO CATION BETWEEN
UNION MEMBER AND YOU
REPRESENTATIVE AND NOT CRIMINAL.
MYSTERY INVESTIGATIONS.
WITH ME DAY TESTIFY IS ONE
VERMONT IS VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF ORANGE COUNTY
GOOD MORNING MR MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS ONE VERMONTERS AND I
AM THE FIRST VICE PRESIDENT WHAT
THE ASSOCIATIONS OF ORANGE
COUNTY DEPUTY SHERIFFS AND A
MEMBER OF THE ORANGE COUNTY
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT.
OUR ASSOCIATION REPRESENTS ABOUT
THIRTY NINE HUNDRED ACTIVE AND
RETIRED SWORN PEACE OFFICERS ALL
TOGETHER.
FROM THE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE
PROBATION DEPARTMENT NO SEE
PARKS.
AB ONE THIRTY SEVEN IS AN
IMPORTANT BILL FOR TWO PRINCIPAL
RATE REASONS.
FIRST IT CLARIFIES EXISTING LAW.
THE LAW ALREADY REQUIRES THAT
OFFICER TO BE INFORMED OF THE
NATURE OF THE INVESTIGATION.
THIS BILL IS NOT CREATING
FURTHER PROTECTION AND SIMPLY
CLARIFYING EXISTING ALONG IN A
VERY LIMITED AND PRECISE WAY.
WE HAVE SEEN DEPARTMENTS GIVE
LITTLE MORE THAN THE CHARGE
ITSELF AND NO OTHER INFORMATION
SUCH AS THE DATE TIME.
OR GENERAL CHARACTERIZATION.
SECOND THE BILL WOULD PROVIDE
PRIVILEGE TO THAT PLACE TO SHARE
INFORMATION WITH THEIR LABOR
REPRESENTATIVES.
WE HAVE HAD DEPUTIES TALK TO
THEIR LABOR REPRESENTATIVES
ABOUT THINGS THEY HAVE SEEN SUCH
AS WORKING CONDITION STAFFING
XTERRA.
AND BE COMPELLED TO DISCLOSE
THOSE CONVERSATIONS WITH
MANAGEMENT.
THIS --
CREATES A CHILLING EFFECT.
OFFICERS WILL NO LONGER WANT TO
COME TO US THEIR REPRESENTATIVES.
AND WE THINK THAT'S SIMPLY WRONG.
WHAT THAT WE REQUEST YOUR YES
VOTE ON AB ONE THIRTY SEVEN
THANK YOU?
THANK YOU NEXT.
RESEARCHER MEMBERS JIM LEVIN ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OR
COUNTY DEPUTY SHERIFF'S ALSO
LONG BEACH POLICE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION AND THE FRATERNAL
ORDER OF POLICE --
AGAIN I JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT.
WHAT'S ALREADY BEEN ADDRESSING
THAT I THINK IT'S REALLY REALLY
IMPORTANT AT THIS BILL --
HAS ABSOLUTELY NOTHING TO DO
WITH CRIMINAL ACTIVITIES OR
VIOLATIONS.
THINK WE NEED TO FRAME THIS AS A
EMPLOYER AND EMPLOYEE --
BILL REGARDING THAT RELATIONSHIP
AND THE DUE PROCESS --
THAT'S ALREADY ENTITLED TO THESE
OFFICE SO WE ARE SIMPLY
CLARIFYING EXISTING LAW IN TWO
PARTS OF THIS BILL --
THAT WE HAVE FOUND THROUGH --
MANY OF OUR JURISDICTIONS HAS
BEEN CIRCUMVENTED THIS POINT--
SO THERE'S CASE LAW ALREADY ON
THE BOOKS WERE SIMPLY CODIFYING
IN CLARIFYING --
EXISTING LAW --
AGAIN ANY CRIMINAL ACTIVITY
INVESTIGATION IS SEPARATE THAT'S
A SEPARATE INVESTIGATION ANY
HEIGHTENED ADMINISTRATIVE ISSUE
THAT OFFICER GOES OUT ON A
MINISTRY TO BELIEVE WHAT WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT HERE ARE MORE
ADMINISTRATIVE INFRACTIONS.
THINGS LIKE WHAT WE SEE
ROUTINELY.
OF BRINGING --
BRINGING DISCIPLINE ON THE BRING
LIABILITY ON THE DEPARTMENT --
ROOM DISCOURTEOUS TREATMENT IF
SOMEBODY A MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
HERE YOU SWEAR --
THINK ABOUT SIR YOU KNOW TRAFFIC
STOPS OR TOWING SITUATION IN IN
THE JAIL SETTING IT COULD BE
THAT THE FOOD WAS BROUGHT TO YOU
THAT WAS COLD AND IT SHOULD BEEN
HOT.
THAT'S A COMPLAINT THEY CAN BE
REGISTERED AGAINST AN OFFICER
EVERY SINGLE COMPLAINT HAS TO BE
INVESTIGATED --
SO WHAT WE'RE ASKING FOR HERE IS
SIMPLY --
DAYTIME GENERAL CHARACTERIZATION
AHEAD OF TIME AS THE LAW
REQUIRES A AND THEN PRIVILEGED
COMMUNICATION AROUND THE
COMMUNICATION THAT THAT OFFICER
IN A LABOR SETTING HAS WITH
THEIR LABOR REPRESENTATIVES THAT
AT THIS POINT HAS --
THAT APPARENTLY THERE'S A
LOOPHOLE IN THE LAW SIR IS
PRIVILEGED.
BUT THE COMMUNICATION FOR
WHATEVER REASON FROM THE OFFICER
TO THAT LABOR REPRESENTATIVE IS
NOT US WE ARE CREATING A
RECIPROCAL PRIVILEGED
COMMUNICATION --
AND WITHOUT ANSWER I BOTH THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
JOHN LEVEL ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF DEPUTY --
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF CODE ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS THE CALIFORNIA COLLEGE
AND UNIVERSITY POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION.
CALIFORNIA NARCOTICS OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION AND THE LA COUNTY
PROFESSIONAL PEACE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION.
ALL IN SUPPORT OF A VERY GOOD
SENSE BILL.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
NAME ORGANIZATION MYSTERY
MEMBERS RAINY PERRY THERE AND
READING ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PATROL AND POOR I CAN SUPPORT.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS PAUL CURRY
ON BEHALF CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONS
SUPERVISORS ORGANIZATION IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
CHAIR RICE FROM OF THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ARE THERE.
ANY OTHER SUPPORT ANY ONE IN
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
STATE [inaudible]
GOOD.
COULD YOU PLEASE MAKE ROOMS LIKE
THIS MORE THAN [inaudible]
PUT
[inaudible]
THE THE OKAY [inaudible]
SO.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE --
LIZZY GIVEN WHAT THEY SELL YOU
CALIFORNIA UNFORTUNATELY WE ARE
IN OPPOSITION TO AB --
ONE THIRTY SEVEN WE BELIEVE THAT
THIS BILL WILL IMPEDE EFFECTIVE
MISCONDUCT INVESTIGATIONS AND
MAKE IT MORE DIFFICULT TO HOLD
OFFICERS ACCOUNTABLE WHEN THEY
COMMIT MISCONDUCT.
I'M CURRENT LAW.
AS AS I SAID DOES IT DOESN'T
PRECLUDE HAVING DISCLOSING ANY
OF THIS INFORMATION DURING AN
INVESTIGATION.
IN FACT IT IS OFTEN PROVIDED I'M
DURING INVESTIGATION --
WHEN THE AND WHEN THEY WOULD?
HELP WITH A PRODUCTIVE AND FAIR
INVESTIGATION.
UNFORTUNATELY NOT ALL OF THIS
INFORMATION IS ALWAYS READILY
AVAILABLE DURING EVERY
INVESTIGATION I'M SOMETHING IS
SOMETIMES SOMETHING AS SIMPLE AS
THE DATE AND TIME.
OF THE INCIDENT ISSUE --
MAY NOT BE AVAILABLE OR OR
ACCURATE --
AND THIS COULD BE TO SIMPLY
BECAUSE THE PERSON WHO MADE THE
COMPLAINT GOT THE DATE WRONG AND
SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT.
IF THAT INFORMATION IS NOT
AVAILABLE OR IF IT IS NOT
ENTIRELY ACCURATE THAT THAT IS
NOT A MEANS FOR OVERTURNING ANY
DISCIPLINE THAT COULD RESULT
FROM.
FROM SUSTAIN FINDING MISCONDUCT
I'M SIMILARLY THE TITLE OF ANY
POLICIES ORDERS RULES PROCEDURES
OR DIRECTIVES ON IT THIS COULD
ALSO NOT BE FULLY KNOWN AT THE
ONSET OF AN INVESTIGATION.
THERE COULD BE INFORMATION THAT
COMES OUT DURING THE COURSE OF
THE INVESTIGATION THAT MIGHT.
LEAD TO THE AGENCY TO TO WANT TO
INVESTIGATE ANOTHER FORM OF
MISCONDUCT THAT WASN'T IN THE
ORIGINAL COMPLAINT OR THAT
WASN'T --
THOUGH THE AGENCY WASN'T AWARE
OF AT THE ONSET OF THE
INVESTIGATION.
SO -- SO
AGAIN WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT.
IF AN OFFICER HAS COMMITTED
ACTUAL MISCONDUCT THAT THEY ARE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE AND THAT THEY
ARE THAT THEY ARE DISCIPLINED
AND THAT --
JUST BECAUSE SOME OF THIS
INFORMATION ISN'T AVAILABLE THAT
THAT DOESN'T WHILE THE OFFICER
TO COMPLETELY AVAILABLE EVADE
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR MISCONDUCT.
I I ALSO JUST WANT TO EMPHASIZE
THAT POLICE MISCONDUCT IS VERY
SERIOUS ISSUE IN CALIFORNIA --
WIN A COMMUNITY MEMBER.
HAS CONCERNS ABOUT AN OFFICER'S
INTEGRITY.
THAT CONCERN NEEDS TO BE --
MEANING FULLY INVESTIGATED AND
TAKEN SERIOUSLY AS IT IS ONLY A
VERY SMALL PERCENTAGE OF
COMPLAINTS OR SUSTAINED IT IS IN
THE SINGLE DIGITS --
AND IN MANY AGENCIES IT'S LESS
THAN 5% AND SO THIS IS NOT A
SYSTEM.
ALREADY IN WHICH MEMBERS OF THE
FEEL LIKE THERE ARE CONCERNS ARE
TAKEN SERIOUSLY AND THAT IS WHY
MOST PEOPLE WHO EXPERIENCE
MISCONDUCT DON'T EVEN BOTHER TO
FILE A COMPLAINT.
AND SO WE FEEL THAT THIS BILL
WILL MAKE THAT PROBLEM EVEN
WORSE IT'LL RACKED MORE OF A
SHIELD TO PLEASE ACCOUNTABILITY
SO FOR THOSE REASONS WE ARE POST.
THANK YOU.
MARCO GEORGE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION --
WE OPPOSE ON AB ONE THIRTY SEVEN
BECAUSE IT MAKES IT MORE
DIFFICULT TO TAKE CORRUPT OR
ABUSE OF POLICE OFFICERS OFF THE
STREETS.
AND ALTHOUGH I APPRECIATE THE
AMENDMENT STATES DON'T GO FAR
ENOUGH --
THESE THIS BILL WOULD CAUSE
SERIOUS DAMAGE TO INVESTIGATIONS
INTO POLICE.
MISCONDUCT.
UP BY PREVENTING INVESTIGATORS
FROM QUESTIONING THE OFFICERS
SUSPECTED ABOUT MISCONDUCT.
I THINK WE NEED TO JUST STEP
BACK A MINUTE AND HISTORICALLY
ON THIS IS PART OF THE POLICE
OFFICERS BILL OF RIGHTS THESE
WERE ON BILLS OF RIGHTS WERE
ENACTED.
IN THE NINETEEN SEVENTIES AND IT
WAS A PUSH BACK AGAINST THE
CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT AND
AGAINST THE CASES OF POLICE
BRUTALITY THEY WERE ENACTED IN
THE NUMBER OF STATES.
AND SO WHAT WE SEE NOW IS
ANOTHER ATTEMPT IN THE FIVE ON
THE FACE OF THE CURRENT MOVEMENT.
TO FOR POLICE TRANSPARENCY TO
HOLD POLICE OFFICERS ACCOUNTABLE
IS TO EXPAND THAT POLICE OFFICER
BILL OF RIGHTS.
AND THIS IS NOT IN THE INTEREST
OF THE CITIZENS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
THESE RIGHTS THAT THEY COULD TRY
TO CHARACTERIZE SAYS EMPLOYER --
EMPLOYEE RIGHTS ARE FAR MORE
EXPENSIVE THAN ANY OTHER CIVIL
SERVICE EMPLOYEE HAS IN THE
STATE.
THEIR MORE EXPANSIVE THAN ANYONE
ELSE WHO WOULD BE QUESTIONED
ABOUT MISCONDUCT.
OR ON ANYTHING THAT MIGHT MORPH
INTO MISCONDUCT WE DON'T GIVE
SPECIAL RIGHTS. TO MILITARY SO
OF SPECIAL RIGHTS TO FIREMAN WE
DON'T GIVE SPECIAL RIGHTS TO THE
MENTALLY ILL.
SO THERE IS NO REASON THAT THESE
PUBLIC SERVANTS.
WHO SHOULD BE ACCOUNTABLE TO THE
PUBLIC SHOULD BE GIVEN THE
SPECIAL RIGHTS?
AND WE KNOW UNFORTUNATELY THAT
THERE ARE --
FREQUENTLY ARISES THE NEED TO
QUESTION POLICE OFFICERS IN THE
STATE AND THAT SOMETIMES THAT
DOES --
BECOME ABOUT SERIOUS MISCONDUCT.
AND WE HAVE THE EXAMPLES --
JUST THIS MORNING THERE WAS
RELEASED --
BY THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
AT BERKELEY --
A REPORT THAT WAS RECEIVED WRAP
IT UP OKAY OF IN THE LAST TEN
YEARS TWELVE THOUSAND APPLICANTS
FROM POLICE OFFICERS HAVE BEEN
CONVICTED OF CRIMES RANGING FROM
PETTY THEFT TO MURDER.
SO THIS IS AN ATTEMPT TO ROLL
BACK POLICE ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY AND WE ASK FOR YOU
TO OPPOSE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER.
IN OPPOSITION.
NAME IN ORGANIZATIONS.
MEDI HIGHER CALIFORNIA CIVIL
LIBERTIES ADVOCACY AND STRONG
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MEASURE MEMBERS CHORUS ALSO ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION OPPOSITION.
EMILY HARRIS OF ELLA BAKER
CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS IN
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
BOB.
I'M REALLY CONFUSED --
HEAD.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
MISTER QUIRK.
ALL RIGHT --
FIRST HAVE A QUESTION FOR MR
CELLS YELLOW IF YOU COULD COME
FORWARD.
I HAVE A QUESTION FOR THE ACLU
AS WELL.
I HAVE LOTS OF QUESTIONS.
OKAY SO MISTER SELLS YELLOW --
WHAT IS THE EXACT NATURE OF THE
OBJECTION FROM THE SHERIFF'S?
THE CONCERN THAT WE HAVE WITH
THIS BILL RESPECTFULLY IS THE
CONCERN WE HAD WITH THE PRIOR
BILL -- THAT
THE THE FRANKLY LAW ENFORCEMENT
MANAGEMENT SPECIFICALLY --
TAKES A LOT OF TRYING TO CHOOSE
THE RIGHT WORD --
BUT CONCERN OR WHATEVER --
THAT WE DON'T DO ENOUGH TO
DISCIPLINE OFFICERS WHO ARE
WORTHY OF DISCIPLINE AND SO IN
IN THIS CONTEXT AND THERE HAVE
BEEN OTHER BILLS THIS IS NOT THE
ONLY BILL.
WITH THE BILLS THAT ATTEMPT TO
EXPAND EMPLOYEE RIGHTS FURTHER
UNDER.
FULL BORE WERE SENSITIVE --
TO AND SO PROVIDING ADDITIONAL
UP THE RIGHT TO HAVE THIS
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION.
AGAIN MAY CAUSE AN INVESTIGATION
OF ON NOT SOMETHING THAT WAS
MERITORIOUS TO THE DISCIPLINE
ITSELF THAT WAS TO THE ACTION
HAPPEN OR DID IT NOT AND WAS THE
DISCIPLINE APPROPRIATE BUT IF
YOU DIDN'T PROVIDE THE RIGHT
INFORMATION AT THE RIGHT TIME IS
THAT.
THE TECHNICAL GROUNDS FOR
THROWING OUT THE DISCIPLINE.
OKAY BUT THERE'S ALREADY.
A REQUIREMENT TO SAY. TO INFORM
THE OFFICER OF THE GENERAL
NATURE OF THE AND THE OF THE
CHARGE AND TO GIVE THAT IN
ADVANCE --
SO THIS IS JUST DEFINING WHAT
THAT INFORMATION WISE YOU COULD
PRESUMABLY.
PUTTING AMENDMENT IN THE BILL
WHICH WOULD SAY IF THAT
INFORMATION ISN'T AVAILABLE.
OR THERE'S AN HONEST MISTAKE IN
GIVING THE DATE AT SAID OR YOU
COULD WRITE THE BILL IN THAT WAY.
THIS IS THEY ALREADY HAVE THE
RIGHT FOR SOME INFORMATION THIS
IS JUST DEFINING AT OUR IF THERE
WERE SOMETHING PUT IN THE BILL
SUCH THAT --
DO YOU THINK THIS IS TOO MUCH
INFORMATION TO BE GIVEN OR DO
YOU.
YOU KNOW IF IT ISN'T TOO MUCH
COULD THIS BE THEN --
REMEDY BY AN AMENDMENT TO THE
BILL IF SAYING THAT --
IF THE DATE WASN'T KNOWN OR IF
THE INFORMATION WASN'T KNOWN IT
DIDN'T HAVE TO BE GIVEN.
IT'S NOT IT THROUGH THE CHURCH
ON AMENDMENT WE'VE SUGGESTED IF
IT WERE ON THE TABLE WE
CERTAINLY CONSIDER BE HAPPY TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR IN STAFF --
BUT THE BILL BEFORE US IS WHAT
BEFORE ISN'T EITHER IT DOES
SOMETHING EITHER IT EXPANDS THE
INFORMATION THAT HAS TO BE GIVEN.
OR IT DOESN'T DO ANYTHING IF IT
DOESN'T DO ANYTHING BEN NOT SURE
WHY WE NEED A BILL EIGHT BUT IN
YOUR OPINION THIS DOES EXPAND
THE INFORMATION.
YEAH THERE'S NO DEFINITION OF
WHAT GENERAL NATURE ME I THINK
BY THE FACT THAT THERE'S A BILL
HERE IT EXPANDS WHAT HAS TO BE
GIVEN.
I SEE ALL RIGHT WELL IT MAKES
SENSE THANK YOU --
A FOR THE ACLU.
SO -- YOUR
NAME AGAIN IS.
LIZZY.
LIZZY YOU CAN YOU CAN
[inaudible]
OKAY -- SO
DO YOU LOOK AT THIS IS AN
EXPANSION OF THE INFORMATION OR
I THINK IT --
I MEAN I I AGREE WITH MR SAYS
BILLS ALSO --
THAT -- YOU
KNOW IT IS.
A BILL BEFORE FOR THIS COMMITTEE
I THINK IT CERTAINLY CAN BE READ
AS AN EXPANSION I THINK THAT YOU
KNOW RIGHT NOW THE NATURE OF THE
OFFENSE ISN'T TO FIND.
I THINK AS I SAID OFTEN THE DATE
TIME AND DATE THAT THE
INFORMATION IS GIVEN LOCATION
DEPENDS HOW HOW WE WOULD DEFINE
A GENERAL CHARACTERIZATION OF
THE CONDUCT --
AND AND AND SO I THINK THAT IT.
IT'S CAN CERTAINLY BE
INTERPRETED AS AS AN EXPANSION.
YOU YOU WOULD INTERPRET IS AS AN
EXPANSION YES.
ALL RIGHT --
THANK YOU I WON'T BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL THEN.
IS MISSPELLED ON MR LOVELL SO
YOU MENTIONED AND I KNOW THAT
THERE IS THE WAY IT'S DONE IN
PRACTICE BUT FOR PURPOSES OF LAW.
AND YOU MENTIONED THAT THIS DOES
NOT APPLY TO ANY PROCEEDINGS
WHERE THERE'S ALSO CRIMINAL
PROCEEDINGS IN NATURE.
AS I READ THE BILL THERE'S TWO
CLAUSES THAT NARROW IT THERE IS
THE OPENING PARAGRAPH AND THEN
SECTION J..
SECTION JAY SAYS THAT THE
SECTION TURNS SOLELY WITH
CRIMINAL ACTIVITIES SO AS I READ
THAT IF THEIR CRIMINAL
ACTIVITIES AND OTHER THINGS THAT
ARE BEING INVESTIGATED THIS
WOULD APPLY IS THAT YOUR
UNDERSTANDING.
SO ERTAINLY IN THIS WAS TOUCH
UPON BY THE OPPOSITION THIS
DOESN'T PRECLUDE IF IN IT IF.
THE OFFICERS BROUGHT IN ON AN
ADMINISTRATIVE ISSUE.
AND ONE SIDE INVESTIGATION AND
SUSAN QUESTIONING BEGINS AND
THEN IT TRANSITIONS INTO ANOTHER
ISSUE THAT MAY HAVE CRIMINALITY
THERE'S NOTHING HERE THAT
PRECLUDES THAT FROM HAPPENING.
A TIME OUT IS GIVEN THE RIDDLER
WERE GIVEN AN OPPORTUNITY TO TO
TALK WITH HER LABOR
REPRESENTATIVE OR THEIR WITH
THEIR ATTORNEY AT SAID IT
DOESN'T PRECLUDE OR STOP ANY
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION.
RIGHT I UNDERSTAND THAT BUT MY
CONCERN SO HERE'S MY CONCERN ON
THE HYPOTHETICAL WE HAVE A
POLICE OFFICER IS BEING
INVESTIGATED FOR SEVERAL THINGS
SUMMER THE MINOR THINGS THAT
YOU'VE MENTIONED.
IN ADDITION THERE ARE
ALLEGATIONS OF SAY SEXUAL
ASSAULT.
THE INVESTIGATOR KNOWS OF ONE
ALLEGATION OF SEXUAL ASSAULT
LET'S SAY THEY WERE FIVE SEXUAL
ASSAULT INCIDENTS WHEN ALL OF A
SUDDEN THIS OFFICER KNOWS
EXACTLY WHAT THE INVESTIGATOR
KNOWS IT LIMITS THE
INVESTIGATORS ABILITY TO
UNDERSTAND.
THE SCOPE OF WHAT'S HAPPENING
AND SO BY GIVING THIS MUCH
INFORMATION I THINK WE'VE NOW.
HAND CUFF TO THE INVESTIGATOR
INTO REALLY GETTING TO THE
BOTTOM OF WHAT'S GOING ON NOT
ALL ALL INTERJECT ON THAT --
IN AND WITH REASON IS I SAW WAS
A CAPTAIN FOR THIRTY YEARS I WAS
A MANAGER CITED HIS
INVESTIGATION SUFFERS A SERIOUS
CHARGES RATE.
THAT BE A CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION
IT WOULD NOT BE IN THE MINISTRY
OF INVESTIGATION.
RACE SO WHERE ANALYZE THAT
STATED THAT'S WHAT I DON'T
UNDERSTAND IS I READ THIS LAW
YOU COULD HAVE BOTH HAPPENING
SIMULTANEOUSLY RIGHT NO AND I
UNDERSTAND A PRACTICE THAT MAY
NOT HAPPEN WHAT I'M SAYING
THOUGH IF IT'S I UNDERSTAND THAT.
WHAT I'M SAYING IS IF AN
ALLEGATION SURFACES A FELONY OR
SERIOUS CRIME?
IT WILL BE TREATED AS A CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION NOT THE MYSTERY
INVESTIGATION THAT'S THAT'S HOW
IT'S DONE.
AND THAT WE REPRESENTS FROM C.
H. P. AND OTHER AGENCIES IN HERE
THAT CAN TALK ABOUT THAT BUT IF
THAT ALLEGATION SURFACES.
IT'S GOING TO BE TREATED AS SUCH
NOT A LESSER NOT A LESSER YOU
GOT MORE SERIOUS CRIME.
RIGHT I I UNDERSTAND YOU
OBVIOUSLY HAVE VASTLY MORE
EXPERIENCE HIGH TO MISTER COOPER
AND I'M NOT SAYING YOU DON'T.
I JUST I'M VOTING ON A BILL TO
GIVE CERTAIN RIGHTS RIGHT AND
THAT'S MY CONCERN SO WHATEVER'S
HAPPENING PRACTICES ONE THING I
RESPECT THAT.
BUT THIS ESTABLISHES LAW AND AS
I READ THE OPENING PARAGRAPH IT
CAN APPLY TO ANY ACTION THAT
LEADS TO DISMISSAL THIS MOTION
SUSPENSION REDUCTION SALARY
WRITTEN REPRIMANDED TRANSFER FOR
THE PURPOSES OF PUNISHMENT
EXCLUDE THINGS THAT ARE SOLELY
CRIMINAL.
BUT NOT THINGS THAT ARE MIXED IN
NATURE.
CAN YOU EXPLAIN IF I'M
MISREADING IT PLEASE SO THIS
DOES NOTHING TO IT TO IMPACT.
ADVERSELY A CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION I THINK AGAIN
NOTHING YOUR CONCERNS ARE STILL
GOING TO BE.
THERE ALREADY BEING ADDRESSED
THAT OFFICER STILL GONNA BE
BROUGHT UP ON CRIMINAL CHARGES
THERE'S GOING TO BE A SEPARATE
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION.
THIS BILL DOES ABSOLUTELY
NOTHING TO IMPACT THAT
INVESTIGATION ALL THIS IS DOING
IN THIS IS NOT ADDING ANYTHING
IT'S NOT AN EXPANSION.
THE COURT THERE'S BEEN TWO COURT
CASES ALREADY IN TWO THOUSAND
AND FOUR RECORDING HINRICH
VERSUS THE COUNTY OF ORANGE SAYS
AT A MINIMUM A GENERAL
DESCRIPTION OF THE ALLEGATIONS
MUST BE GIVEN.
LATER IN TWENTY SIXTEEN ALAN'S
VERSUS THE CITY IS CITY OF
SIERRA MADRE A DISCLOSURE SAID
INFORMATION MUST BE ACCOMPLISHED
REASONABLY PRIOR ANY
INTERROGATION.
THAT'S ALREADY EXISTING LAW THE
PROBLEM IS IN PRACTICE THERE'S
NO EXPANSION.
I I JUST I I THINK IT USED TO BE
WERE WERE BASICALLY HIT.
HERE IN SUPPORT OWN IN
CLARIFYING.
WHAT IS CURRENT LAW IN A SPACES
NESSA'S A MEAN THAT'S REALLY
WHAT WE'RE DOING WE'RE WE'RE
TRYING TO ENCOURAGE WHAT IS
ALREADY EXISTING LAW THAT IS NOT
BEING?
EXECUTED TO THEIR CURRENT LAW
THAT REQUIRES AS MUCH DETAIL
ABOUT THE INCIDENT BE GIVEN TO
AN OFFICER.
IS TO SAY THAT AGAIN OF HIS
THEIR CURRENT LAW THAT REQUIRES
THAT THIS MUCH DETAIL BE GIVEN
TO AN OFFICER.
SHOW AS RELATED TO THE INFORMAL
IS AGENCIES ARE TO OUR OUR
DETERMINE ERROR OR THERE
DISCERNING THIS DIFFERENTLY WE
HAVE AGENCIES ALL OVER THE STATE
THERE ARE DID THEIR DEFINING IT
ONE WAY AND OTHER AGENCIES
DEFINING IT ANOTHER LARGER
AGENCIES ARE BETTER ABOUT
DEFINING IN PROVIDING MORE
INFORMATION SOME.
OF THE SMALLER AGENCIES ARE NOT
THE MESS I AND THAT'S THE ISSUE
WITH A SMALLER AGENCIES
MISTRESSES ELLO MISSPOKE MOST
HERE LARGE SHARES DEPARTMENT
PLEASE DEPARTMENTS.
PROVIDE YOU WITH THE INFORMATION
BECAUSE SOMEONE COMES IN THIS
REAL ISSUE COMES OUT A
TIMELINESS YOU WANT
INVESTIGATION DONE A TIMELY
MANNER IF YOU COME IN YOU DON'T
KNOW WHAT HAPPENED WHEN AND
WHERE.
THEN OKAY LET'S TAKE A TIME OUT.
AND YOU GO BACK TO THEN IS
DELAYED SOMETIMES WEEKS
SOMETIMES MONTHS THAT'S WITH THE
BEEN THE BIGGEST ISSUE COME IN
FOR INSTANCE MOST IS COMPLETE
THIS BE HONEST.
IT IS FOR HIS COURTEOUS
TREATMENT OVER HALF PROBABLY
MUCH HIGHER I STOPPED YOU FOR
TRAFFIC VIOLATION YOU MAY
COMPLETE L. DISCOURTEOUS WHELP.
PHARMACIES P. OFFICER I MAYBE
TWELVE OR FIFTEEN STOP IN TODAY.
SEE TELL ME ON THIS DATE IN MAY
THE STOP SO WHAT INTERROGATION
ALL ASKING FOR IS.
THE TIME TO DO THE INCIDENT.
THE LOCATION OF THE INCIDENT.
AND THAT'S IT AND IF TO AFFAIRS
NUMBER TO FIND OUT SO THAT WAY
YOU TELL ME IN SO THEY CAN GO
BACK AND WE HAVE A TICKET THAT
DID THEY WROTE THEY WROTE NOTES
IN THE BACK OF THE TICKET WHICH
CHP DOES.
MR LACKEY WILL TESTIFY THEY CAN
FIGURE OUT WHICH CASE VERSUS
HAVING TWELVE SEPARATE CASES YOU
DON'T KNOW.
SO IT REALLY COMES DOWN TO THAT
AND IF IT'S A CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION NUMBER ONE THERE
TO START A SEPARATE
INVESTIGATION NOT RELY A WITH
DETECTIVES COLONEL INVESTORS
THAT DO THAT.
IN THAT CASE IS REFERRED THE
DA'S OFFICE DOES NOT HANDLE
INTERNALLY IF IT'S IF CRIMINAL
CONDUCT A SUSPECTED SO YOU HAVE.
INVESTIGATORS INVESTIGATE THAT
NOT NOT AN INTERNAL AFFAIRS
TOTALLY SEPARATE CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATORS DO THAT DO THE
INVESTIGATION EVERY FOR TODAY'S
OFFICE FOR PROSECUTION.
SO IT'S A REALLY IT'S A REALLY
AS TWO SEPARATE ISSUES
[inaudible]
OKAY.
CONNECT WITH PROMOTED OF SO --
THANK YOU ALL FOR IT THIS
CONVERSATION.
SO TO CLARIFY I HAVE TWO
QUESTIONS MISTER CHAIR IF THESE
THINGS ARE NOT PROVIDED AS YOU
ARE --
ASKING THAT THEY BE.
SAY AGAIN WHAT HAPPENS TO THE
COMPLAINT.
IF WHAT MODESTO IF YOU'RE NOT
GIVEN THE TIME THE DATE OF THE
INCIDENT THE LOCATION SO IF
THOSE THINGS ARE NOT.
BASED ON WHAT YOU'RE REQUESTING
IN THIS LAW IF THEY ARE NOT
PROVIDED THEN WHAT WOULD HAPPEN
TO THE COMPLAINT WOULD BE
DISMISSED SO IT WOULD BE
CONTINUED SO MAJORITIES CASES
THAT INVOLVE DISCIPLINE.
IT A LOWER LEVEL WE'RE TALKING
LOWER LEVEL DISCIPLINE SO
CORRECTIVE ACTION MAYBE DOCUMENT
COUNSELING SO WE KNOW MOST OF
THESE ARE.
I'LL BE HONEST SICK LEAVE ABUSE
COMPUTER ACCESS --
CONNECTING TO COMING ON THE
COMING OF OF AN OFFICER AND
DISCOURTEOUS TREATMENT THINGS
LIKE THAT.
SO YOU GIVE ME INFORMATION --
WISE IF YOU SAY WE DON'T REALLY
KNOW.
THE COMING WILL WE CAN ASK THIS
QUESTION LET'S CONTINUE THE CASE
SO YOU GOTTA YOU REPRESENTATIVE
THEY HAVE TO HAVE TO FIGURE OUT
OKAY WILL COME BACK IN TWO WEEKS
OR MONTHS.
MY SCHEDULE AVAILABLE WEATHER SO
YOU REPRESENTED OR ATTORNEY OR I
FOR THAT MATTER SO IF YOU HAVE
THE INFORMATION IS DONE THAT DAY.
IF WE'RE WE'RE DOES NOT PUT
OFFICE NOT CONTINUE.
BUT WHEN YOU DON'T HAVE THE
CORRECT INFORMATION YOU CAN'T
COME.
AND TELL WHAT HAPPENED YOU MISS
BECAUSE I DON'T REMEMBER THAT I
DO FIFTEEN TRAFFIC STOP TODAY.
HOW MY GONNA MEMBER WHO WAS RUDE
TO STILL ALL DOES IS NARROW IT
DOWN AND AND I THINK ABOUT THIS
THE DAY IN TIME OF THE INCIDENT?
THE LOCATION OF THE ACCIDENT.
THAT'S OUR ASKING.
FOR NOTHING ELSE AND WHAT BEEN
WITH A SMALL APARTMENT THE
WEATHER BE USING THIS TO THE
SMALL DEPARTMENTS SO LARGER
AGENCY YOU CAN GO TO COURT AND
SUED.
MUST LAWLER TO SEE IF YOUR
RIGHTS ARE BEING VIOLATED YOU
CAN'T GO TO COURT AND SUE.
NEST WE'VE BEEN THE BIG ISSUE
WORDS HAPPEN TO THE SMARTEST
BIGGEST HE'S DO ALREADY.
WELL AND SO --
IN MANY OF THE EXAMPLES THAT YOU
ALL HAVE GIVEN THE COMPLAINT HAS
BEEN A MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC.
RATE CORRECT THE ALL TIME OR
SOMETIMES PHILOSOPHY AND ALL
OFFICER YES OKAY SO THAT WAS
SORT OF MY SECOND QUESTION
BECAUSE YOU KNOW IN MY NECK OF
THE WOODS WE HAVE A SAYING.
SNITCHES GET STAGES AND SO.
I WONDER IF YOU CAN USE THIS
INFORMATION TO KIND OF
TRIANGULATED WHO MAYBE YOUR
FELLOW OFFICER IS WHO'S LODGED A
COMPLAINT.
AND THAT COULD THEN ALSO IMPEDE
YOU KNOW THE INTEGRITY OF THE
INVESTIGATION BECAUSE I WOULD
ASSUME THAT IT TAKES A LOT OF
COURAGE. TO LODGE A COMPLAINT
AGAINST A FELLOW OFFICER IN WHEN
YOU'RE DOING THAT --
BECAUSE IT'S SUCH A CLOSE KNIT
COMMUNITY AND YOU YOU LIVE LIVES
ARE ON THE LINE ALL THE TIME IT
PROBABLY DOES TAKE A ACT OF
COURAGE TO SAY I'M GONNA STEP UP.
AND SAY SOMETHING OR WATCH
COMPLAINT AGAINST INSTANCE IF
THEY THEN HAD THIS ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION YOU COULD
TRIANGULATE WHO YOUR FELLOW
OFFICER IS AND THEN LIKE YOU
KNOW MEET ME IN THE CORNER ON
YOU KNOW THREE O'CLOCK WE ARE.
WHICH IN WHICH ALSO COMPROMISES
THE ABILITY TO HAVE [inaudible]
A HEALTHY.
ACTIVE ROBUST WORK FORCE WHERE
FOLKS ARE ON THE SAME PAGE HERE
TUESDAY TO ADDRESS YOUR CONCERNS
IT'S NOT TELLING YOU WHO FILED
THE COMPLAINT.
**** IT'S JUST IT'S JUST IT'S
JUST TELLING WHAT HAPPENED SO
COULD BE OFF THREE COULD BE THE
PERSON THAT WAS [inaudible]
THE VICTIM.
SO IT COULD BE A COME FROM RIGHT --
VARIETY OF SOURCES SO WE OFFER
DOESN'T KNOW WHO TO COMPLAIN IS.
AND THEN IS THIS THIS IS
CODIFIES WHAT'S ALREADY IN LAW
AND IT IT IT SAYS IT BECAUSE
IT'S IT'S UNFORTUNATE CODIFIED
BECAUSE SOME PEOPLE KNOW CHOOSE
THE BUTTE THAT AND NOT FOLLOW IT.
A MISTER LACKEY IN AND MISS WORK.
GET THE LET ME FIRST OFF SAY
THAT -- I
FEEL VERY QUALIFIED TO TALK
ABOUT THIS TOPIC I MEAN EIGHTEEN
IN MY TWENTY EIGHT YEARS WAS.
SERVING AS OF THE FRONTLINE
SUPERVISOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY.
AND THE MAJORITY OF WHAT YOU'RE
ASKING FOR IS ALREADY PART OF
THE AGENCY I WORK FORCE POLICY.
SO WHAT YOU'RE ASKING FOR IS NOT
EXPANSION IT IS CLEARLY A
CLARIFICATION OR INTERPRETATION.
THAT OTHER AGENCIES.
DO NOT AFFORD.
CERTAIN OFFICERS WHICH CLEARLY.
I THINK THE PRESUMPTION OF
INNOCENCE DOES NOT ONLY APPLY TO
PEOPLE UNDER CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION --
IT HAS TO BE A VERY IMPORTANT
TENET.
THAT.
WHEN ALLEGATIONS ARE BROUGHT
FORWARD THAT THEY REALLY DID
OCCUR?
AND SO WHEN YOU HAVE THESE KINDS
OF REQUESTS OR ARE PARTS OF THE
INVESTIGATION I THINK ALL IT
DOES IS STRENGTHENED.
THE VERACITY OF THE OUTCOME OF
THE INVESTIGATION AND SO I I I
THINK IT'S BEEN A LITTLE BIT
UNFAIRLY CHARACTERIZED BY SOME
MY COLLEAGUES A KID APPEAR.
WHO AREN'T FAMILIAR WITH THE
PROCESS AND SO I WILL TELL YOU
THAT WHAT YOU HAVE IS?
IS NOT ONLY REASONABLE BUT
PROBABLY NO PORTENT THINK YOUR
AND IT SHOULD IT.
I JUST WANNA KNOW.
BASICALLY WHAT'S THE
SIGNIFICANCE OF ASKING ABOUT THE
IN THE INTERNAL AFFAIRS CASE
NUMBER.
I JUST THAT SOMETHING NEW TO ME
AND I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT ITS RELEVANCE AS A LIEN HAS
A FOR THEIR RECORDS.
SEE THE KEEP TRACK OF IT.
WILL THIS IS THIS THE BEST TO
GAZE AT THIS POINT DOES NOT COME
IT'S NOT COMPLETE.
SO WHY WOULD THE CASE NUMBER BE
OF IMPORTANCE [inaudible]
RIGHT.
NOW IF WE WANNA MAKE SURE KEEP
TRACK OF WHAT CASE IT IS.
THAT'S THAT'S THAT'S THAT'S THE
REASON [inaudible]
OKAY.
THANK YOU.
BUT BUT A ALSO I JUST FALL WITH
YOU MISTER LACKEY I MEAN THIS TO
BE HONEST THIS THIS IS A LABOR
BILL.
THIS THE LABOR BILL THE REASON
IS HERE THEM ALL PUBLIC SAFETY
OTHER LESBIAN LABOR COMMITTEE.
THAT'S WHAT A BILL HERE IS LIKE
A TEACHER FOR TEACHERS ACCUSED
OF SOMETHING THEY COME IN.
THERE TOLD A LOT FARMER TOLD A
LOT THROUGH LAW THINGS THAT
PEOPLE ARE TOLD IN THEIR CASES
IN LABOR WHEREVER YOU ARE THIS
IS A SEVENTY LAW ENFORCEMENT.
LASTING FOR A LOT [inaudible]
MS WORKS.
YOU MISTER CHAIR.
SO WE'VE HEARD I THINK DIFFERENT
OPINIONS HERE SOME FOLKS BELIEVE
THAT THIS IS AN EXPANSION OF
RIGHTS AND SOME FOLKS THINK THIS
SORT OF NOT.
IS IT YOUR OPINION MISTER COOPER
THAT THIS IS CODIFYING IT IS NOT
AN EXPANSION OF RATES RIGHT SO A
BIG AGENCY FOR INSTANCE IF YOUR
CHP OFFICER.
HAVE A BIG ENOUGH SEVEN THOUSAND
MEMBERS SO IF THE COMMISSIONER
WAS DOING THAT.
THE UNION CONSUME GO TO COURT IF
YOU WORK FIRST COMMERCENTRE
HUNDRED OFFICERS YOU DON'T HAVE
THE MONEY TO GO A FIGHT IN COURT
TO DO THAT.
SO IF YOU'RE FROM A SMALL ISSUE
YOU'RE BASICALLY SCREWED AND AND
ONE OTHER QUESTION.
IT'S BEEN MADE CLEAR THAT THIS
DOES NOT APPLY TO CRIMINAL
DISCIPLINE CORRECT AND THE
GENTLEMAN WHO WAS SITTING YEARS
WHOSE NAME ESCAPES ME KILLINGS
THE BACK OF HIS HEAD SO I
APOLOGIZE --
HAD SAID EARLIER THAT OR
HEIGHTENED ADMINISTRATIVE
DISCIPLINE RIGHT WHAT'S THE
DIFFERENCE IN HEIGHT
ADMINISTRATIVE DISCIPLINE AND
MORE LOWER LEVEL WHERE WHAT IS
THAT YOU WOULD WEAR ADELINE OR
SOMETHING SIR SHOULD BE AN ADMIN
LEAVE IF IF WE CAN CONSIDER IS
OF SERIOUS NATURE.
AND WE PUT PEOPLE AND LEAVE ALL
THE TIME.
SO WHAT ONLINE NO ON THOSE FOR
SORT OF MORE RUN OF THE MILL OR
TO CITY.
IN CASES LIKE THIS IS GOING TO
RESULT IN CORRECTIVE ACTION OR
MAYBE A DOCKING ACCOUNTS AND
WITH THE REP A LETTER WRITTEN
REPRIMAND SO THE LOWEST LEVEL
POSSIBLE THAT THAT BE LINE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
IT IS A QUESTIONS.
YOU MAY CLOSE MOST COOPER SO FOR
LOT TESTIMONY --
NO TWELVE THOUSAND OFFICERS THAT
WERE COMMITTED PETTY THEFT AND
MURDER THIS IS NOT A CRIMINAL
CASE NUMBER.
ONE IS DOESN'T EXPAND IT
CODIFIES IT.
AND IS NOT EVADING
ACCOUNTABILITY IT IS IT LIKE
SAID THIS COMES DOWN TO IT THESE
FOLKS ARE UNION MEMBERS.
WE WANT TO MAKE IT WORK.
AND THE VAST MAJORITY THESE
CASES.
INVOLVED.
COURTEOUS TREATMENT A PUBLIC.
CONDUCT UNBECOMING AN OFFICER
SICK LEAVE COMPUTER ACCESS.
ITEMS LIKE THAT IMPORTS OF
MAINTAINING GOOD EMPLOYER
EMPLOYEE RELATIONSHIPS IS
PARAMOUNT IN A HARMONIOUS FAIR
PRODUCTIVE WORKPLACE.
AB ONE THIRTY SEVEN WILSHIRE
THAT ONE A PEACE OFFICER IS
NOTIFIED OF A NON CRIMINAL
MINISTRY COMPLAINT.
THERE FOR THE MIDDLE INFORMATION
TO EFFECTIVELY PREPARE FOR
DIRECT INACCURATE BOSSES.
AB ONE THIRTY SEVERAL ALSO SURE
THE COMMUNICATIONS BETWEEN
EMPLOYEE AND HIS OR HER UNION
REP --
CONFIDENTIAL MATTERS WITHIN THE
SCOPE OF THE ORGANIZATION SPREAD
PRESENTATION.
AB ONE THIRTY SEVEN SHARES AT
PEACE OFFICERS ARE MEMBERS.
UP I ACCEPT YOURS AMENDMENTS
ANNA AND I JUST WANNA GO BACK
ONE MORE TIME FOR FOR MY FOR THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SO RIGHT NOW THE LAW SAYS
INFORMED OF THE NATURE OF THE
INVESTIGATION PART TO
INTERROGATION ALL I'M ASKING.
FOR IS THE TIME AND DATE OF THE
ANY INCIDENT [inaudible]
AT ISSUE.
THE LOCATION OF THE INCIDENT
WORD OCCURRED.
AND THE CASE NUMBER.
THAT THAT'S THAT'S ALL WE'RE
ASKING FOR AND I I DON'T THINK
THAT'S TOO MUCH WITH YOUR
TEACHER.
DELEGATION UP IN THIS CLASSROOM
ON THIS DATE THERE'S NOT A BIG
DIFFERENCE SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU --
YOU KNOW WE HAVE A A SET OF
RULES.
THAT WE JUST APPROVED HERE IN
COMMITTEE AND THERE'S A SET OF
RULES THAT ARE WRITTEN DOWN ONE
MINDS IF THE DON'T TALK PASSED
THE S..
THE COMPANION TO THAT IS DON'T
CALL PASSED KNOW.
AND SO DO A LOT OF QUESTIONS
WOULD MEMBERS HERE WHO ARE CHORE.
WHERE THEY WERE?
AND I WAS HOPING THAT.
WE COULD SPEND A LITTLE MORE
TIME DISCUSSING IT NOT
NECESSARILY IN HERE BECAUSE WE
ARE WE HAVE A LIMITED AMOUNT OF
TIME.
AND THIS SEEMS TO BE STILL
MEMBERS [inaudible]
THAT HAVE.
THAT HAVE SOME SOME SOME ISSUES
AND PROBABLY SOME MORE QUESTIONS.
OF EVEN MORE PERPLEXING TO CD
ACLU IN THE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT
ON SAME.
IT'S EVEN MORE CONFUSING --
AND SO -- I
I I HOPE WE COULD HAVE.
GIVEN MAYBE A LITTLE MORE TIME
WEEK FOR THIS TO TO DO THIS IN
THE AUTHOR HAS THE DISCRETION TO
DO WHATEVER YOU WANT SO.
I'M I HAVE MORE QUESTIONS NOW
AND I DON'T WANT TO SIT HERE AND
GO OVERTHAT AND SO I'M I'M
GOING TO ABSTAIN --
MAINLY BECAUSE OF THE QUESTIONS
THAT HAVE COME UP EVEN. FOR
MISTER LACKEY --
SAID IT THIS COULD BE A LITTLE
MORE BAKER.
MISTER CHAIR PERHAPS IF THE
AUTHOR.
WERE WILLING TO WAIT A WEEK AND
TRY TO WORK THINGS OUT
PARTICULARLY WITH THE SHERIFF'S --
AND AND WE BETTER WHAT THE
CONCERNS ARE AND PERHAPS RESOLVE
THEM --
RATHER THAN TAKE A VOTE NOW.
IT'S UP TO YOU IN THE AUTHOR BUT
I WHAT I OFFER THAT TO THE
AUTHOR.
BEFORE WE EVEN CAME IN SO THAT
HE DECIDED HE WOULD COME AND HE
DID SOUND LIKE YOU STILL HAVE A
SECOND OFFER.
OFFERED FEW WOULD LIKE.
WHAT WE CAN DO THAT I MEAN THE
ALBION'S MISTER QUIRK THE CHEESE
OR NEUTRAL --
THE SHERIFF'S --
SHERIFF'S THAT DON'T REALLY DO
ANYTHING THEY NEVER COME WHEN ON
ANYTHING TO BE HONEST.
SO -- WE CAN
DO THAT THIS BILL PASSED OUT
HERE TWO YEARS AGO AT THE PASSED
THE SENATE AND THE ASSEMBLY
[inaudible]
SUCCESSFULLY --
SO I DON'T I'M NOT SURE HOW MUCH
IT DOES --
HOW MUCH AWAY THEN I I'M WILLING
TO DO THAT?
BUT IT'S HARD.
TO DO WHEN YOU COME UP HERE IN
IN HEARING YOU DEAL WITH FACT
AND DEAL WITH FICTION SO THAT'S
THAT'S THE TOUGH PART SO I'M
WELL I'M WELL I'M GOING TO HOLD
OFF IF YOU.
DON'T HAVE MUCH YOU NEED.
TO SO IF YOU WANT TO GO INTO
VOTE WOULD TAKE ABOUT.
WHAT BALL IF YOU GUYS HAVE MORE
QUESTIONS --
AT THE PLEASE ASK I WOULD ALWAYS
I'LL BE HONEST AS FAR AS I THINK
MY OFFICE.
WE WERE.
REALLY APPROACHED ALONG THIS
ISSUE SO I KNOW THAT YEAH THAT'S
WHAT I WAS TRYING TO EXPRESS TO
YOU THAT YOU NEED A LITTLE MORE
MEMBERS.
BECAUSE STUFF Là THESE
QUESTIONS THAT COME UP LAST
NIGHT AND AS WELL AS TRYING.
TO IMPRESS ON YOU THAT YOU NEED
TO SPEND A LITTLE MORE TIME.
AND ADVOCATES FOR THIS NEW THIS
WAS COMING SO I WOULD HOPE THEY
WOULD HAVE TALKED TO EVERY
COMMITTEE MEMBER.
BEEF EVEN BEFORE AND IT GOT A
SCHEDULE THEY DID MISTER CHAIR
OF THE WELL --
OKAY WE SOLD SO WHAT WOULD YOU
WANT.
TO WHAT WE COULD PUT OVER YES
OKAY REPORTED OVER FOUR WEEKS
OKAY UP JUST ONE OF THE THINGS.
THE ACLU AND THE SHERIFFS WERE
BOTH CONCERNED THAT IF THEY
WEREN'T ABLE TO GIVE THE EXACT%
INFORMATION THAT THERE MIGHT BE
AN APPEAL.
PUTTING SOME LANGUAGE IN THAT
WOULD.
RELIEVE SOME OF THAT CONCERN.
I THINK WOULD BE USEFUL AS WELL.
IF IF THEY DON'T KNOW THE EXACT
INFORMATION YEAH I BET I KNOW
PUBLIC THAT THE INFORMATION
AVAILABLE WE DON'T KNOW I DIDN'T
THINK YOU WOULD HAVE ONLY GOT A
MINUTE YES IF YOU COULD --
WORK ON THAT PLUS IF I COULD I
NEED TO UNDERSTAND.
FROM THE SHERIFF'S MANAGEMENT
POINT OF VIEW WHY THEY SEE THIS
IN THIS EXPANSION.
AND FROM THE ACLU AS WELL SO GOD
SO WE CAN.
PUT IT OFF FOR TWO WEEKS AT ONE
I WOULD AND CORRECTED THAT'S WHY
AND BEFORE VOTE ONLY.
BY THE MEASURE THANK YOU.
NEXT WE WILL HAVE MISSED I GREW
A LOT.
CURRY.
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE AJ OUR NUMBER
[inaudible]
FOUR THANK YOU [inaudible]
RUNNING [inaudible]
WELL [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
AND YEAH YEAH [inaudible]
YEAH.
I'M SORRY.
SH.
I DID ONE INTERRUPT.
TO CHAIRMAN MOVE THE BELL SECOND.
MEMBER THE FIRST RULE.
DON'T TALK PASSED BEYOND.
WHAT -- I
WILL PROCEED BECAUSE THIS IS
PRETTY IMPORTANT AND I
APPRECIATE THE MOTION.
I'VE INTRODUCED AJ ARE FOR TO
URGE CONGRESS TO SWIFTLY PASSED
HOUSE RESOLUTION EIGHT THE
BIPARTISAN BACKGROUND CHECKS ACT
OF TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE ALREADY
PASSED LAWS TO REQUIRE UNIVERSAL
BACKGROUND CHECKS WITHOUT ANY
LOOPHOLES.
THIS LAW HELPS REDUCE THE
TRAGEDIES OF GUN VIOLENCE BY
KEEPING FIREMAN FIRE ARMS OUT OF
THE HANDS OF THOSE WHO SHOULD
NOT HAVE THEM.
HOWEVER.
UNTIL WE BRING THIS EFFECTIVE
FIREARM POLICY TO THE WHOLE
COUNTRY A DANGEROUS LOOPHOLE IN
FEDERAL GUN LAWS STILL EXEMPTS
UNLICENSED SELLERS FROM HAVING
TO PERFORM ANY BACKGROUND CHECKS
WHATSOEVER.
BEFORE SELLING A FIREARM.
THIS GAP IN FEDERAL LAW LEAVES
PEOPLE EVEN HERE IN CALIFORNIA
SUBJECT TO THE DANGERS OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO NOT WHO CANNOT
PASS A BACKGROUND CHECK.
OBTAINING FAR ARMS FROM
UNLICENSED SELLERS FROM OUT OF
STATE.
THE MOST COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH
TO ENSURING THAT GUNS ARE NOT
SOLD TO PROHIBITED PEOPLE IS
THROUGH A NATIONAL UNIVERSAL
BACKGROUND CHECKS.
AT THIS POINT OF AT THE POINT OF
TRANSFER OF ANY FIREARM.
BY PASSING AJ OUR FOR OUR
CALIFORNIA LEADERS IN CONGRESS
AND OUR PRESIDENT WILL RECEIVE
THE MESSAGE LOUD AND CLEAR THE
CALIFORNIA FORMALLY AND PUBLICLY
THEM DEMANDS.
THE SPEEDY PASSAGE IS THEN
SIGNING OF H. R. [inaudible]
EIGHT THANK YOU.
AMANDA WILCOX AGAIN I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTERS OF THE BRADY CAMPAIGN
TO PREVENT GUN VIOLENCE.
I'M VERY PLEASED THAT THIS
RESOLUTION IS BEFORE YOU TODAY.
AS TOMORROW IS THE TWENTY FIFTH
ANNIVERSARY OF THE BRADY BILL.
OF THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
BRADY BILL BACK IN THE EARLY
NINETIES.
ALSO TOMORROW WILL BE THE VOTE
ON HR EIGHT IN THE HOUSE AND THE
FULL HOUSE.
OF ONE OF THE FIRST VOTES IN THE
CHAMBER PIECE OF FIREARM
LEGISLATION. FOR MANY MANY YEARS
ACTUALLY SINCE THE NINETIES --
SO THIS IS GOOD TIMING --
TO MOVE THIS RESOLUTION FORWARD --
THE BRADY LAW HAS STOPPED MANY
MANY GUN SALES ESTIMATED THREE
MILLION PURCHASES HAVE PREVENTED.
ON AVERAGE OF THE SIX HUNDRED
AND NINETEEN INDIVIDUALS ARE --
PREVENTED FROM BUYING A GUN
EVERYDAY --
THAT'S SIGNIFICANT HOWEVER THERE
AS YOU KNOW THERE'S CLEARING
LOOPHOLES IN THE LAW PRIVATE
PARTY TRANSFERS --
IN IN INTERNET CELLS ARE NOT
SUBJECT TO THAT LAW UNDER
FEDERAL LAW CALIFORNIA WE'VE HAD
UNIVERSAL BACKGROUND CHECKS
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY ONE AND I
HAVE TO EMPHASIZE THAT
BACKGROUND CHECKS UNIVERSAL
BACKGROUND CHECKS.
IS THE FOUNDATION OF FOR ALMOST
ALL THE OTHER BILLS THAT WE HAVE
ENACTED IN THE STATE IT IS THE
IMPORTANT POLICY --
CALIFORNIA --
WHICH DOES HAVE THE STRONGEST
GUN LAWS AGAIN BUILT ON
BACKGROUND CHECKS FOR EVERYBODY
WE'VE HAD A 55% --
FIRE MORTALITY RATE KLEIN SINCE
OUR HIGH IN NINETEEN NINETY
THREE THAT'S MORE THAN FOUR
TIMES ALMOST FOUR TIMES OTHER
DECRYPT DECREASE IN THE REST OF
THE NATION --
SO I WOULD CONTEND THAT OUR GUN
LAWS WORK BACKGROUND CHECKS WORK
CALIFORNIA CANNOT DO IT ALONE WE
NEED FEDERAL A LAW TO MAKE SEATS
POLICIES NATIONWIDE --
AND I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THIS
RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU ARE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES THE SUPPORT --
JOHN LEVEL ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CALLER SHE SAYS HE
ASIAN WERE IN STRONG SUPPORT
WE'RE UNIQUELY SITUATED BECAUSE
ON HAPPILY IN THESE ARE
NATIONWIDE STATISTICS.
AN ACTIVE SHOOTER INCIDENT TAKES
PLACE ONCE EVERY EIGHT DAYS ON A
COLLEGE CAMPUS THANK SO.
THIS IMPORTANT YES IT IS.
YES NAME AN ORGANIZATION.
ALLEN QUICK BAY AREA STUDENT
ACTIVISTS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING DANNY CANDLE
BECAUSE OUR BEHALF OF GIFFORD'S
LAWCENTER TO PREVENT GUN
VIOLENCE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
JIM WEINBERG ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
CALIFORNIA SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MANY HAD CALIFORNIA CIVIL
LIBERTIES ADVOCACY AND STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ARE ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
HELLO GERMAN.
WELCOME BACK [inaudble]
SURE.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS IT'S AN
HONOR TO BE HERE AGAIN AND TO
TALK ABOUT A LOT OF A VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUES THAT ARE.
GONNA COME BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE --
WITH REGARDS TO THIS --
A JOINT RESOLUTION WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION AND THE REASON WE ARE
IS THAT --
WE THINK THAT IT IS ASKING IN
AND FOCUSING ON SOMETHING THAT
HAS BEEN REPORTED MOST RECENTLY
MULTIPLE TIMES AS HAVING NO
IMPACT ON GUN VIOLENCE AND THAT
BEING.
UNIVERSAL BACKGROUND CHECKS ARE
BACKGROUND CHECKS ARE
REGISTRATION IN PARTICULAR --
STUDIES THAT WE DIDN'T
COMMISSION --
STUDIES THAT WERE THE ARE.
ARE UP HAD BEEN PEER REVIEWED IN
A AND AND OUT THERE ARE ARE
POINTING OUT TO THE FACT THAT.
TO PUT.
AN IMPORTANCE ON THESE THINGS IN
ORDER TO REDUCE.
GUN VIOLENCE ARE NOT GOING TO BE
EFFECTIVE.
AND WE'RE INTERESTED IN REDUCING
GO PUTTING OUT --
PROGRAMS AND IDEAS THAT THAT
AREN'T GOING TO GET TO THE
MATTER OF THE ISSUE --
WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF DEMOCRATS
IN CONGRESS.
WHO AGREE WITH US AND AND WILL
MAKE THEIR THEIR VOICES KNOWN?
ON THE FLOOR WHEN THIS --
RESOLUTIONS TAKEN UP IN AND READ --
THERE'S THERE'S ALSO.
THIS IS THE FIRST HEARING
THEY'RE GONNA BE MANY ISSUES AND
I THINK THAT.
THAT IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US --
TO TO BEGIN TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION BASED ON WHAT THE
REALITY IS GOING TO BE IN THE
FUTURE.
OTHER OR THERE IS ONE SUPREME
COURT CASE THAT HAS BEEN
ACCEPTED BY THE SUPREME COURT.
TWO MORE THAT ARE THAT ARE
PENDING THAT --
LOOK LIKE THE SUPREME COURT IS
TAKING --
INTEREST IN.
AND IT'S GOING TO CHANGE THE
DYNAMIC OF ALL OF THE GUN LAWS.
AND MAYBE IT'S TIME TO SIT DOWN
AND TALK ABOUT CRIME CONTROL
INSTEAD OF GUN CONTROL THAT AS
THESE STUDIES THAT HAVE BEEN
PUBLISHED HAVE SHOWN THAT --
ARE AN EFFECTIVE AT REDUCING --
AGAIN A GUN VIOLENCE THANK YOU --
THAT'S SMART OPINION ON THIS
RESOLUTION THANK YOU GET.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE RECORD DâN RE
WITH NATIONAL RIFLE ASSOCIATION
ALSO YOUR FIRST YEAR PA TODAY.
IN OPPOSITION AJ ARE.
FOR STUDIES OF SHOWN THE
BACKGROUND CHECKS ARE NOT
EFFECTIVE IN FACT WITH THE STUDY
AT A CALIFORNIA THAT MR PERATIS'
REFERENCE THAT REALLY COULDN'T
SHOWING THAT BENEFIT OF IT.
ON THERE'S A MAJOR
ENFORCEABILITY ISSUE WHEN IT
COMES TO BACKGROUNDCHECKS ON
PRIVATE TRANSFERS --
WHICH LENDS ITSELF TO US SELECT
HAVE.
COMMONPLACE ACTIVITIES THAT ARE
NOT CRIMINAL THAT --
ARE PROHIBITED UNDER THESE TYPES
OF LAWS SUCH AS LOADING A GUN
YOUR BEST FRIEND THAT DOESN'T
MEET A CERTAIN EXEMPTION --
AND SO.
AT THE END OF THE DAY WE HAVE.
HAVE THIS SUSCEPTIBILITY TO
PEOPLE TO NOT BE FAIRLY
PROSECUTED ACROSS WHERE WE
SHOULD FOCUS ON UTILIZING
FIREARMS LAWS THAT ACTUALLY GO
AFTER BAD PEOPLE THAT ARE
PROHIBITED AND WE ALREADY HAVE
LAWS TO DO THAT ON THE FEDERAL
LEVEL -- AND
SO LET'S NOT EXPAND THE LAWS
THAT ARE ONLY GOOD IMPACT LAW
ABIDING CITIZENS CRIMINALS ARE
NOT GETTING THEIR FIREARMS
THROUGH THROUGH DEALERS THEY'RE
GETTING THEM THROUGH ILLICIT
MAINS.
AND THIS BILL GENERALLY DOES NOT
GO AFTER THAT ARE THESE TYPES OF
BILL SO WITH THAT WE SAN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU I THINK YOU
I THINK I FILLED MENTION I'M
SAMPRAS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
GUN OWNERS CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU SAM.
AND IT IT OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
YOU MAY CLOSE.
I US FOR A VOTE ON THIS
RESOLUTION.
SO I DON'T WANT.
TO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD --
AS WE ALL KNOW.
PROBABLY BACKGROUND CHECKS WILL
BE VERY IMPORTANT.
SPECIALLY SENSE --
PROBABLY MANY IF NOT MOST OF THE
MASS SHOOTINGS.
WERE BY LAW ABIDING [inaudible]
NO RECORD [inaudible]
CITIZENS.
AND SOMEHOW WITH MENTAL PROBLEMS
IN AND SO WE NEED TO HAVE SOME
SOME WAY OF CAPTURING THOSE.
WE HAVE A WE ALREADY HAVE LAWS
ON THE BOOK IT WAS MENTIONED
EARLIER ABOUT HOW TO DEAL WITH
CRIMINALS.
WHO HAVE POSSESSION OF WEAPONS --
HOPEFULLY BACKGROUND CHECKS WILL
HELP US --
CAPTURE THE DONE A FIVE THOSE
WHO DANCE ON THE MOST HEINOUS.
FIREARMS CRIMES IN THIS COUNTRY --
SOMEHOW WE NEED TO FIGURE THAT
OUT AND HOW TO CAPTURE THAT AND
SO I AGREE WITH --
WITH THE OPPOSITION THAT WE NEED
TO DO MORE --
TO MAKE SURE WE GET THE GUNS OUT
OF HANDS OF CRIMINALS AM AND WE
SHOULD AND AND HOPEFULLY ONE DAY.
THEY TOO CAN COME WITH
LEGISLATION IDEAS ON HOW WE CAN.
GET THE GUNS OFF THE STREET AND
OUT OF THE HANDS OF PEOPLE WHO
WILL HARM SOCIETY --
I'M WAITING IN. ONE DAY I MAY
SEE THAT SO --
UNTIL THEN --
WE WILL BE WORKING ON BACKGROUND
CHECKS AND AND OTHER RESOLUTIONS
THAT YEAR YOU'RE PROVIDING WITH
THE CHEERS RECOMMEND AN AYE VOTE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ON AJ ARE FOR THE MOTION IS BE
ADOPTED JONES SAWYER --
JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY NO BAUER-KAHAN I
BAUER-KAHAN I DEEP.
DEEP NOT VOTING KAMLAGER-DOVE
HAVE [inaudible]
HI.
GIVE ME DEEP I KAMLAGER-DOVE
HAVE KAMLAGER-DOVE AYE QUIRK AYE
QUIRK AYE SAN DIEGO.
SAN DIEGO I WICKS I WICKS I THE
RESOLUTION PASSES RESERVATIONS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OKAY.
BUT ALSO MISTER BONTA --
GO OVER THERE OKAY.
BOTTOM ITEM --
BONTA ITEM NUMBER. THIRTY AB
THIRTY TWO ITEM NUMBER
[inaudible]
ONE SECOND.
ALRIGHT I GET THE PICTURE HERE --
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS AB THIRTY TWO OF AND
CALIFORNIA'S USE OF FOR PROFIT
PRIVATE PRISONS AND MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE THE COMMITMENT THAT
WE NEED TO HAVE [inaudible]
TO I AM.
REHABILITATION AND SUCCESSFUL
REENTRY PROGRAMS AND REDUCTION
OF RECIDIVISM RATES RIGHT NOW
ARE FOR PROFIT PRIVATE FOR
PROFIT PRIVATE PRISONS.
HAVE A FIDUCIARY DUTY TO THEIR
SHAREHOLDERS NOT TO THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA.
I AM AND I THINK WE NEED TO AND
THERE THE USE OF FOR PROFIT
PRIVATE PRISONS ARE ARE BILL
PROPOSES THAT WHEN --
IS STARTING JANUARY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY THERE BEING NO NEW
CONTRACTS OR RENEWAL OF
CONTRACTS BEFORE WITH FOR PROFIT
PRIVATE PRISONS WE'VE BEEN
REDUCING.
OUR RELIANCE ON A FOR PROFIT
PRIVATE PRISONS ARE BRINGING.
OUT OF STATE PRISONERS IN FOR
PROFIT PRIVATE PRISONS BACK AT
THE CALIFORNIA BUT WE STILL HAVE
ABOUT FOUR THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED
INMATES IN FIVE PRIVATELY
OPERATED FOR PROFIT PRIVATE
PRISONS.
AND WE NEED TO FACE THAT OUT AND
AND OUR RELIANCE OF RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
I HAVE WITH ME HERE KAI JACKSON
WITH THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF THE SPONSOR OF AB THIRTY TWO
STATE SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TONY THURMOND.
GOOD MORNING --
COMMITTEE CHAIR COMMITTEE STAFF
I APPRECIATE YOU HAVING IS HERE
FOR THIS CONVERSATION AS A
SIMILAR BONTA SAM KAI JACKSON ON
BEHALF OF SUPERINTENDENT TONY
THURMAN. TO GIVE YOU THE BOTTOM
LINE UP FRONT THE SUPERINTENDENT
IS COMMITTED TO DISRUPTING THE
SCHOOL TO PRISON.
PIPELINE AND PROVIDING SCHOOLS
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION WITH THE
TOOLS TO ADDRESS ISSUES SUCH AS
SUSPENSIONS ISOLATION WILL FOR
THE FINANCE AND EXPULSIONS WHICH
OFTEN TIMES ARE THE ON RAMP TO
OUR CHILDREN. TO OUR STUDENTS
INTO THE JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM
WHILE WE UNDERSTAND THIS BILL
SPECIFICALLY LOOKS AT PRIVATE
PRISONS AS YOU'LL HEAR FROM SOME
OTHER ADVOCATES --
WE BELIEVE THERE IS A ROOM FOR
EDUCATION IN THE LARGER
DISCUSSION.
WE UNDERSTAND THAT IN ORDER TO
IMPACT THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM AND TO MITIGATE PREVENT
OR ROLL BACK.
OUR STUDENTS ENTERING JAILS
PRISONS AND YOU WERE NOW SINCE
IT CENTERS IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
WE INTERACT WITH THEM EARLY
PRIOR TO THIS HAPPENING.
IN TERMS OF WHAT THE
SUPERINTENDENT IS DOING THERE
ARE NUMBER OF ISSUES TO OUT
BRIEFLY MENTION HERE TODAY ONE
AS WELL FOR THE FINANCE.
WHICH IS BROADLY DEFINED AS WHEN
STUDENTS EITHER DISOBEY.
THE ORDER OF A TEACHER OR SCHOOL --
IN THAT COULD.
WHAT IS HE SAID ACROSS
[inaudible]
SO YEAH. TO WHERE ELIMINATING
PRIVATE PRISONS SO COULD USE.
STICKS TO HER PRIVATE PRISONS
AND WHY WE NEED TO ELIMINATE
THEM.
NOW THIS MAY BE A SUBSET OF THAT
OR HELP TO GET TO THAT MAYBE YOU
COULD REFERENCE IN HOW WE WHAT
DON'T NEED TO BUILD MORE PRIVATE
CAUSES BY [inaudible]
PROVIDING.
WRAPAROUND SERVICES YES THE
SUGGESTION. TO HELP TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE DON'T HAVE TO BUILD MORE
PRISONS BECAUSE WE HAVE MORE
PEOPLE.
READING CARCERI MORE PEOPLE SIR
WHAT THE SUPERINTENDENT'S A
SUGGESTION AND I KNOW SHE'LL SIR
WITH THE SUPERINTENDENT WANTS TO
DO IS MITIGATE PREVENT A ROLL
BACK THE NUMBER STUDENTS.
GOING INTO THE JAILS THUS
REDUCING THE NUMBER OF PRIVATE
PRISONS THAT WE NEED --
FOR FOR INDIVIDUAL SIR THANK YOU
NEXT.
AS CHAIR MEMBERS RANCHERA WITH
THE RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S
ASSOCIATION NUMEROUS STUDIES
HAVE DEMONSTRATED.
THAT THE MAIN OBJECTIVE OF THESE
WALL STREET PRIVATE PRISON CASH
COWS IS TO MAXIMIZE PROFITS FOR
THEIR SHAREHOLDERS. FOR PROFIT
PRIVATE PRISON COMPANIES
ACCOMPLICES GOAL BY IMPLEMENTING.
RELAX HIRING STANDARDS REDUCE
STAFFING LEVELS INADEQUATE
EMPLOYEE TRAINING AND BY PAYING
THEIR WORKERS SUBSTANTIALLY LESS
IN WAGES AND BENEFITS WHEN
COMPARED TO PROFESSIONAL PUBLIC
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS.
AS A RESULT OF THIS TOXIC PROFIT
MAXIMIZING FORMULA PRIVATE
PRISONS HAVE A SUBSTANTIALLY
HIGHER RATE OF BOTH IN MADE ON
STAFF ASSAULTS.
AN INMATE ON INMATE ASSAULTS.
IS NOW SEEKING CAR SERRATION
CORPORATIONS ARE TRADE ON AND
MUST MEET FINANCIAL THE
FINANCIAL GOALS.
OF THE INSTITUTIONAL INVESTORS
AS A CEO OF CORRECTIONS
CORPORATION OF AMERICA NOW
CALLED CORE CIVIC ONE STATED.
INMATES ARE A COMMODITY IN OUR
LINE OF WORK.
TREATING INMATES LIKE
COMMODITIES MAY PROVE BENEFICIAL
TO THE BOTTOM LINE OF THESE
CORPORATIONS BUT DOES LITTLE TO
REHABILITATE INMATES OR PROMOTE
PUBLIC SAFETY.
UPON THE RELEASE OF THEIR COME
THEIR COMMODITIES BACK INTO OUR
COMMUNITIES.
ACADEMIC STUDIES HAVE ALSO SHOWN
THE RECIDIVISM RATE IS HIGHER
FOR FOR PROFIT PRISONS --
INMATES WHEN COMPARED TO
PROFESSIONAL PUBLIC FACILITIES.
OFFICIAL GOVERNMENT REPORTS IN
ADDITION TO THE ACADEMIC
RESEARCH HAS DEMONSTRATED THAT
FOR PROFIT PRIVATE PRISONS ARE
JUST AS EXPENSIVE.
AND SOMETIMES MUCH MORE
EXPENSIVE THAN PUBLICLY OPERATE
CORRECTIONAL INSTITUTIONS.
PRIVATE FOR PROFIT PRISONS HAVE
ALSO BEEN SHOWN TO ENDANGER THE
COMMUNITIES IN WHICH THEY RESIDE.
A TEN YEAR STUDY OF PRISON
ESCAPES.
SHOWED THAT FOR PROFIT PRIVATE
PRISONS HAD TWENTY TIMES THE
NUMBER OF ESCAPES.
FROM SECURE FACILITIES THAN
THOSE FROM CDC ARE.
PRIVATE PRISON COMPANIES.
LOWER THE BAR WHEN IT COMES TO
THE CORRECTIONS PROFESSION AND
WHILE WE IN THE PRIVATE AND THE
PUBLIC SECTOR.
ARE CONSTANTLY TRYING TO IMPROVE
OPERATIONS THE PRIVATE FOR
PROFIT CORPORATIONS SEEK ONLY TO
IMPROVE PROFITS.
AND THE FOR THOSE REASONS
RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION
STRONGLY.
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS BILL IN A
POST PRIVATE PRISONS THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU --
JOHN LEVEL ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF DEPUTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS.
OF CALIFORNIA SISSY ATION OF
CODE ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS.
CONGRESS OF RACIAL EQUALITY.
CALIFORNIA NARCOTICS OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
CORRECTIONAL SUPERVISORS
ORGANIZATION AND THE LA COUNTY
PROFESSIONAL PEACE OFFICERS ALL
IN SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
UP ANY [inaudible]
ANY OTHER.
IN SUPPORT ONE BACK IS FOR ELLA
BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
MARCO GEORGE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
A MERRY HAD CALIFORNIA CIVIL
LIBERTIES ADVOCACY AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU --
JIM LIMBURG ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
AND WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
COULD YOU MAKE A CORY CELLS
LOWER YOUR ALL OVER THE MAP
TODAY ON MY DAY IN THE BOOK.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
BURST COURCELLES ELLO HERE ABOUT
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION --
RESPECTFULLY IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL OUR CONCERN IS NOT ONE
ABOUT THE THE PROPRIETY OF THE
MERITS OF PRIVATE PRISONS OR
PUBLIC PRISONS OR JAILS OR
WHATEVER.
OUR CONCERN IS THAT REMOVING A
TOOL -- IN
CDC OURS EFFORTS TO ADDRESS
OVERCROWDING THAT THEY HAVE DONE --
WITH I WOULD SAY SOME SO THE
LAST SEVEN EIGHT YEARS TO
ADDRESS --
COURT ORDERED POPULATION
REDUCTIONS --
WE'RE TAKING AWAY TOOL THAT HAS
BEEN HELPFUL IN THAT EFFORT --
I WOULD SAY THAT'S THE CASE FOR
OTHER.
USES OR METHODS OR APPROACHES IN
AND REALLY THAT'S THAT'S WHAT
WERE CONCERNED ABOUT BECAUSE
WHAT WHAT WE WHAT WE SEE
POTENTIALLY HAPPEN AND IS ONE OF
TWO THINGS --
ONE IF WE TAKE AWAY TOOL TO DEAL
WITH OVERCROWDING.
WE DON'T ADDRESS THE
OVERCROWDING AND WE END UP WITH
PEOPLE BEING RELEASED UNDER THE
EXISTING THREE JUDGE ORDER --
THAT HAS ALREADY PUT IN PLACE A
COMPLIANCE OFFICER WHO HAS THE
AUTHORITY TO RELEASE PEOPLE AND
SO IF THIS OPTION IS NOT
AVAILABLE --
THAT BECOMES A POSSIBILITY THE
OTHERS SONORA THAT WERE
CONCERNED ABOUT AND I WOULD SAY
TOO MUCH HIGHER DEGREE.
IS ONE THAT INCREASES PRESSURE
TO HOUSE MORE FELONS AND COUNTY
JAILS SO WE'VE PARTNERED WITH
THE STATE --
TO TRY TO APPROPRIATELY HOUSE
OFFENDERS WE'VE DONE THAT WE
HAVE --
FELONS IN OUR JAILS THAT WE DID
WE GET PAID WE'RE FLYING BUT
UNDERTAKEN THAT AS BECAUSE
CHALLENGES AND AND WE'RE DEALING
WITH THOSE CHALLENGES AND YOU IN
THIS COMMITTEE IN THE
LEGISLATURE HAVE BEEN VERY
HELPFUL IN PROVIDING MUCH NEEDED
FUNDS TO REHABILITATE AND
RENOVATE FACILITIES. TO ADDRESS
THE CHANGING MISSION OF JAILS
OVER THE YEARS AND WE APPRECIATE
THAT CERTAINLY.
BUT WE ARE FACING CHALLENGES
FROM THE DIFFERENT INMATE FELON
POPULATION THAT WE HAVE NOW AND
WE'RE CONCERNED THAT IF AGAIN IF
WE TAKE A TOOL OUT OF THE TOOL
BOX THAT CREATES MORE PRESSURE
TO SAY HEY WE'RE GONNA LOOK AT
COUNTY JAILS.
AS AN OPTION NOW TO PUT THESE
PEOPLE AND INSTEAD OF HAVING
THEM IN PRIVATE PRISONS AREN'T
SAYING THAT HAVING A STATE
PUBLIC PRISON OR HAVING THEM IN
SOME OTHER TYPE OF PROGRAM OR
SOME OTHER ENVIRONMENT.
AND AND FRANKLY THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT IS THIS
INCREASED PRESSURE TO HAVE MORE
PEOPLE IN COUNTY JAILS --
WITHOUT THE PROPER STAFFING
WITHOUT THE PROPER FUNDING
WITHOUT THE PROPER FACILITIES
AND PROGRAMMING SO BASED ON
THOSE TWO CONCERNS WERE OPPOSED
THE BILL THANK.
THANK YOU OF AN EMAIL WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS --
AS THERE WAS ONE THING --
BROUGHT UP.
AND THAT IS THAT IN SOME CASES.
ARE CDC ARE WILL RUN A PRISON
THAT IS OF RENTED FROM A PRIVATE
BUSINESS.
I DO THINK THAT THAT'S PROBABLY
OKAY -- WHAT
DO YOU WHAT IS YOUR SITUATION
THERE? ONE ZERO OPERATED BY YEAH
SO THEY'RE OPERATED BY THE OTC
ARE BUT THERE.
ARE ARE ARE FOCUSED WITH THIS
BILL IS.
FACILITIES PRISONS THAT ARE
OPERATED BY FOR PROFIT PRIVATE
OKAY SO COMPANIES IF THEY LEASE
THE LAND IT'S BASICALLY --
IT'S IT'S A LAND ARRANGEMENT BUT
IT'S RUN BY IS OVERSIGHT
ACCOUNTABILITY TRANSPARENCY
COMMITMENT TO REHABILITATION
REENTRY --
LAURIE RE RECIDIVISM RATES THAN
THAT'S NOT OUR FOCUS IN THE BILL
PERFECT THANK YOU.
MR LACKEY YEAH JUST REAL QUICKLY
I ALSO TO WOULD LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE CONVERSATION
BETWEEN OUR OFFICES.
AND YOUR OPENNESS TO AMEND THE
BILL TO THE POINT WHERE I GET TO
A SUPPORT RIGHT NOW I'LL BE --
NOT.
FORTY YOU FOR THE PRODUCT OF
CONVERSATION STRIKING.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER.
THANK YOU MAKE YOU MAY CLOSE.
JUST A QUICK POINT ABOUT THE
OPPOSITION'S ARGUMENT WHICH I
UNDERSTAND BUT I ALSO
RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE WITH --
I UNDERSTAND THIS WAS SEEN AS A
TOOL WHEN WE HAD A COURT ORDERED
CAP I THINK IT WAS WRONG TO USE
FOR PROFIT PRIVATE PRISONS THAN.
I EVEN MORE WRONG NOW BECAUSE
WERE BENEATH THE CAP WE DON'T WE
DON'T NEED. TO USE THEM AND WE
HAVE CAPACITY IN OUR EXISTING
FACILITIES THROUGHOUT.
THE STATE WE WE WE GOT A LIST OF
RATED CAPACITY AND THERE'S
LITERALLY HUNDREDS OF BEDS
THOUSANDS OF BEDS --
AT PUBLIC FACILITIES THAT HAVE
PROGRAMMING AND TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY AND OVERSIGHT
THAT WE COULD USE --
IF NECESSARY WITH THAT WITH THE
APPROPRIATE ARRANGEMENT CELL
WHILE I UNDERSTAND THE ARGUMENT
I I RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE WITH
THAT -- AND
EVEN AND NOW WE DON'T HAVE THAT.
THIS IS ABOUT STANDING WITH OUR
VALUES IN CALIFORNIA DOING
WHAT'S BEST FOR CALIFORNIA AND
IT'S BEST TO HAVE.
A STRONG SUPPORT SOME PROGRAMS
THAT ARE COMMITTED TO
REHABILITATION AND ARE RE ENTRY
IN THE REAR --
RECIDIVISM RATES AND DIE FOR
THAT REASON I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE ON A. B. THIRTY
TWO THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES.
THANK YOU AND HAVE BEEN PART OF
THE REASON WHY --
I DID THE AUDIT ON
REHABILITATION PROGRAMS BECAUSE
WHEN THEY ARE SUCCESSFUL.
AND I CAN HOPEFULLY.
IN MY MY LAST SIX YEARS AGO
DOESN'T COME BACK TO HAUNT ME
HOPEFULLY IT.
AT THE REHABILITATION.
PROGRAMS WORK THEY'LL BE FEWER
AND FEWER PEOPLE BOTH HOPEFULLY
IN JAILS AND IN STATE PRISONS SO
THAT WE NEVER HAVE THAT PROBLEM
WHICH IS JUST OVERCROWDING AT
THE STATE LEVEL WHERE THEY HAVE
TO START.
FIGURING OUT SOMETHING OR HAVE
ANOTHER COURT ORDER WHICH IS
WHAT I THINK THE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT AND OTHERS ARE SAYING
THAT WE'RE NOW FORCED TO COME UP
WITH REMEDIES HOPEFULLY IF IT
EVER HAPPENED THAT WE WE DON'T
GO BACK TO WHAT.
WE'RE COMFORTABLE WITH WHICH IS --
GO TO THE PRIVATE SECTOR AND
EVEN AN EMERGENCY --
STATE EMERGENCY AS WE KNOW
NATIONAL WHERE DO YOU CAN JUST
SAY ANYTHING BUT THAT'S A WHOLE
NOTHER DISCUSSION.
AND THAT THAT WE COME UP WITH
THE OUR OVERCROWDING THE WAY WE
DID IT I AGREE WITH YOU MISTER
BONTA WAS WAS --
WAS WRONG WITH WE WERE JUST.
WE WERE JUST SHOOTING FROM THE
HIP AND THAT'S WHY --
THAT FIRST NATIONAL PUSHING
PEOPLE DOWN TO THE STATE --
BECAME PROBLEMATIC AND THAT'S
WHAT WE HAD TO PROVIDE FUNDING
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL THE LOCAL
JAIL LEVEL.
AND SO -- IF
WE DO.
REALLY WELL WITH YOU KNOW SEE C.
OUR OFFICE NO LONGER BIG ON C.
WHICH IS HOUSING PEOPLE AND
BASED ON OUR REHABILITATION --
WE SHOULD NEVER HAVE TO DEPEND
ON GOING TO PRIVATE PRESENCE ON
RECOMMENDED AND I THANK YOU.
ON A. B. THIRTY TO THE MOTION IS
TO PASS THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER.
CHEN SIR I LACKEY.
LACKEY NOT VOTING BARRICADE HAN
HI BAUER-KAHAN I DEEP.
THING.
DEEP STAIN KAMLAGER-DOVE OF
KAMLAGER-DOVE AYE QUIRK AYE
QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WICKS.
THE BILL PASSES GRADUATIONS
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU STAFF.
MISTER KING IS IN HERE SO OUT
PRESENT.
IN THE PAST.
THE GAL PLEASE.
THERE RIGHT.
ITEM NUMBER [inaudible]
ELEVEN RIGHT.
THEY WILL BE AN ITEM NUMBER.
ELEVEN AND MISTER JONES SAWYER
IF YOU'D LIKE TO PROCEED.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS --
AB TWO TWO SEVEN REVISE A STATE
LAW BY ALLOWING FOR THE
ASSESSMENT OF CERTAIN PINES THAT.
FUN COURT OPERATIONS COURT
CONSTRUCTION AND RESTITUTION
FUND ONLY AFTER FINDING OF A
DEFENDANT'S ABILITY TO PAY MOVE
THE BELL.
SO I WOULD BE REMISS AND BEFORE
I GET TOO FAR TODAY'S
PRESENTATION --
OUR ALSO LIKE TO TAKE A MOMENT
OF BANKS.
ARE TO THE LATE JEFF ADACHI.
ARM ELECTED PUBLIC DEFENDER IN
SAN FRANCISCO WHO HELPED US
THINK THROUGH SOMEBODY THREE
WEEKS AGO --
HE WAS A CHAMPION ANY WAS
SOMEONE THAT WAS.
THAT IS NOT ONLY RESPECTED BUT A
HE WAS A TIRELESS ADVOCATE FOR
THE POOR AND PEOPLE OF COLOR
COLOR.
JEFF PASSED AWAY UNEXPECTEDLY
OVER THE WEEKEND.
HIS LEADERSHIP AND ADVOCACY WE
SORELY MESSED.
AS FOR THIS BILL TRIAL COURTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE ASSESS A
NUMBER OF FINES AND FEES WHEN
THE DEFENDANT IS CONVICTED OF
CRIMINAL OFFENSES INCLUDING
TRAFFIC OFFENSES.
WHEN A CRIMINAL FINES AND FEES
SYSTEM WAS SET UP THE COURTS
WERE ALLOWED TO LEVY PENALTY
ASSESSMENTS ON BASS FINDS WHICH
COULD BE AS MUCH AS? THIRTY FOR
EVERY TEN DOLLARS OF THE FINE.
BALLING THE GREAT RECESSION
STATE AND LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
HAVE INCREASED BINDS TO A LEVY A
GENERAL FROM PRESSURE BUT HAVE
DONE THIS ON THE BACKS OF POOR
DEFENDANTS.
IN. FIFTEEN SIXTEEN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAD AROUND.
TWELVE BILLION DOLLARS IN
OUTSTANDING UNCOLLECTED DEBT.
ON JANUARY EIGHTH TWENTY
NINETEEN THE SECOND COURT OF
APPEALS HELD THAT THE MANDATORY
IMPOSITION OF THREE SPECIFIC
PINES WITHOUT REGARD FOR
DEPENDENTS ABILITY TO PAY.
IS A VIOLATION OF AN
INDIVIDUAL'S DUE PROCESS.
THAT RULING FOLLOWS A TWENTY
SIXTEEN DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
LETTER THAT NOTES THAT ONE FINDS
ARE NOT GEARED TOWARDS PUBLIC
SAFETY.
BUT RATHER TOWARDS RAISING
REVENUE.
THEY CAN CAST DOUBT ON THE A
PARTIAL --
SYSTEM.
THAT'S WHY WE DON'T SET FOR
TRAFFIC OFFICES WE DON'T GIVEN
QUOTAS.
IS NOT BASED ON HOW MUCH THEY
MAKE ISN'T BASED ON THE ACTUAL
INFRACTION.
THIS BILL SIMPLY CALL IT
CODIFIES THE APPELLATE COURT
RULING REQUIRING A FINDING OF
ABILITY TO PAY PRIORTO THE
ASSESSMENT.
OF SELECT FINE MEMBERS ARE
RESPECTFULLY ASK THREE AYE VOTE
WITH ME TO TESTIFY IS MARGO
GEORGE FROM THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU --
I JUST WANNA SAY I WAS REALLY
TOUCHED BY THE CHAIRMAN'S
COMMENTS ABOUT JEFF ADACHI.
ON HE WAS BOTH A FRIEND AND THE
HERO -- FOR
US OF THE PUBLIC DEFENDERS OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND FOR
OUR CLIENTS HE WAS A TRUE
WARRIOR.
AND SO I AM VERY TOUCH THAT YOU
DID THAT THANK YOU --
TURNING TO THE A. B. R. --
TWO TWO SEVEN LET ME TELL YOU
ABOUT THIS DUANE US WHO IS --
THE SUBJECT OF THE CASE MISS
DWAYNE US WAS THE HOMELESS POOR
WOMAN WITH YOUNG CHILDREN WITH
CEREBRAL PALSY.
AS A RESULT OF MULTIPLE FINES
FOR DRIVING ON A SUSPENDED
LICENSE WHICH SHE COULD NOT PAY.
SHE SPENT OVER FIFTY ONE DAYS
ADDITIONAL IN COUNTY JAIL.
THAT WAS THE HARDSHIP OF COURSE
FOR HER.
AND A LOS AND SHE WAS YOU KNOW
BASICALLY BEING IMPRISONED FOR
HER POVERTY.
BUT IT IS ALSO NONSENSICAL
BECAUSE IT WAS A LOSS FOR THE
TAXPAYERS AS WELL.
NOT ONLY DID THERE WAS NO
REVENUE COLLECTED WE HAD TO PAY
FOR HER TO BE INCARCERATED FOR
ALMOST TWO MONTHS FOR POVERTY
[inaudible]
I'M.
THE CHAIRMAN SAID THAT BETWEEN
US IS THE EXISTING LAW AND AB
TWO TWO SEVEN CODIFIES THAT THAT
IS CORRECT.
UNFORTUNATELY THE SAN BERNARDINO
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY HAS
SENT A LETTER TO THE COURT OF
APPEAL ASKING THAT THE OPINION
BT PUBLISHED.
BUT EVEN SO THIS IS EXISTING LAW.
JUST LAST WEEK.
IN A TIM VERSES --
INDIANA.
THE US SUPREME COURT HELD THAT
THE PROTECTION AGAINST EXCESSIVE
FINES GUARDS AGAINST THE USES OF
GOVERNMENTS PUNITIVE OR CRIMINAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITY.
THIS SAFEGUARD WE HOLD IS
FUNDAMENTAL TO OUR SCHEME OF
ORDERED LIBERTY.
AND AS THE WINNERS COURT SAID IN
THEIR OPINION.
BECAUSE THE ONLY REASON THE
DEFENDANT CANNOT PAY THE FINE
AND FEES AS HER POVERTY.
USING THE CRIMINAL PROCESS TO
COLLECT TO FIND SHE CANNOT PAY
IS AN CONSTITUTIONAL.
WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
K..
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MANY HAD CALIFORNIA CIVIL
LIBERTIES ADVOCACY AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
WHEN THIS IS IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
PRETTY BARE.
YOU MAKE ANY --
QUESTIONS FROM [inaudible]
APPEAR.
WHAT A SHOW NUMBER?
IS CHAIRMAN MY GUESS MY IN MY
QUESTION. TO YOU IS [inaudible]
IF.
IF PART OF THE THE ARM OF THE
FUN.
THAT IS COLLECTED.
OF WILL GO INTO.
THE VICTIM COMPENSATION PROGRAM --
EIGHT WE ELIMINATE THIS STREAM
OF EVER OF REVENUE --
HOW DOES THAT AFFECT THAT THAT
VICTIM COMPOSITION PROGRAM?
OKAY SO I PUT IT.
I BELIEVE THE THE A I DON'T
ANSWER ROB THE I CAN FIND OUT DE
THE IMPACT ON OUR AYE UP FROM
HOPING AND I BELIEVE IT IS NOT
GOING TO BE AS I SIGNIFICANT.
BECAUSE IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT IS
ON COLLECTED.
A LOT OF TIMES WE DON'T GET MOST
MONEY THAT GOES INTO THAT.
SPECIALLY CONSIDERS THESE
DESIGNED TO PRESERVE THE
CAMPAIGN ANYWAY.
AND WE JUST DID HOPE PART OF
THIS YOU'RE NOT GONNA GET THE
MONEY ANYWAY SO TO CRIMINALIZE
AN AD PENALTIES ON TOP OF THAT.
JUST FURTHER PUSHES THAT PERSON
IN A PROPERTY THAT THE END OF
THE DAY --
AND THAT'S WHY I MENTIONED ABOUT
THE THE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS THAT
ARE ON COLLECTED.
A LOT OF THAT INVOLVES A LOT OF
POOR PEOPLE --
BUT I WILL FOR I'LL GET YOU A I
CAN GET YOU A BEFORE WE BEGIN
SALAS COMMITTEE I CAN OF FIND
OUT EXACTLY WHAT THE IMPACT IS
AND WE GO TO APPROPRIATIONS.
WHICH IS.
WHERE THEY'RE DEFINITELY GOING
TO LOOK AT THAT --
I PAGANI DANCER IN ANYWAY.
I THINK ONE THING ON A THREE
WEEKS AGO WHEN JEFF ADACHI WAS
HERE HE WAS ACCOMPANIED BY THE
TREASURER OF THE COUNTY AND CITY
OF SAN FRANCISCO.
WHO BASICALLY SAID THAT ON NGOR
COLLECTING THE FEES BECAUSE THE
ADMINISTRATIVE OVERHEAD MADE IT
NOT WORTH THAT?
IN OTHER WORDS IT COSTS MORE TO
TRY TO COLLECT.
MONEY FROM PEOPLE WHO DON'T HAVE
IT.
BAND THEY THEN DOING IT SO IT
JUST YOU KNOW IT'S A LOSS
BASICALLY IS WHAT HE SAID OR
WASH.
I'M NOT SURE OF THE EXACT
NUMBERS.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
I JUST WOULD LIKE TO SAY THAT I
THINK THAT THE CONCERN OVER THE
VICTIMS RESTITUTION FUND IS A
SERIOUS.
ONE AT ITS DEPLETING VERY VERY
QUICKLY AS A YOU MAY BE AWARE
WE'RE BOTH ON SUB.
FIVE SO HOPE THIS WILL TRIGGER
OUR CONVERSATION AND OUR DESIRE
TO MAKE SURE THAT FUND IS NOT GO --
RIPLEY BECAUSE OF BILLS LIKE
THIS -- ONE
THIS IS CLEARLY WORTHY OF MY
SUPPORT AND I APPRECIATE YOU
BRING IT FORWARD WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE [inaudible]
OKAY.
ON AB TWO TWO SEVEN THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER AYE JONES
SAWYER AYE LACKEY AYE LACKEY AYE
BARRICADE HAND I'VE BARRICADE
HAND I'D DEEP.
DEEP STAIN KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE AYE QUIRK AYE
QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO [inaudible]
WICKS.
THE MEASURE PASSES THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THE FOR I AM.
THREE FOUR MISTER CHANG AB FIFTY
FOUR PIECE OFFICE OF BODY
CAMERAS IN AB SIXTY ONE GUN
VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDER.
WHICH EVERYONE YOU WANT TAKE
FIRST I'LL DO AB FIFTY FOUR FOR
SINCE MY WITH THIS IS ALREADY
HERE.
SO AB FIFTY FOUR IS CLEAN UP
LEGISLATION TO AB SEVEN FORTY
EIGHT WHICH WAS PASSED AND
SIGNED INTO LAW LAST YEAR.
UNFORTUNATELY THERE WAS A
DRAFTING ERROR IN BECAUSE OF THE
THREE DAY IN PRINT ROLE WE WERE
NOT ABLE TO MAKE THE CORRECTION.
HIGHER TO THE BILL BEING PASSED
OFF THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR AND
CONCURRED ON SET TO THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE.
AGAIN THE ONLY ONE THAT WAS LEFT
OUT IS A PROVISION THAT STATES --
IT'S I BELIEVE IT'S IN YOUR
ANALYSIS BUT AGAIN THE WORDS THE
ESTIMATED DATE FOR DISCLOSURE
OFF AND EIGHT THEN IT GOES INTO
THE VIDEO OR AUDIO RECORDING.
WE BELIEVE THAT BY ADDING THIS
AMENDMENT DOES GIVE LAW
ENFORCEMENT JUST IS A LITTLE
MORE FLEXIBILITY AROUND THE DATE
AND WHEN THAT --
BODY CAMERA INFORMATION NEEDS TO
BE RELEASED I KNOW THERE ARE
CONCERNS ABOUT COST BUT AGAIN
THIS BILL AMENDED THE PUBLIC
RECORDS ACT.
WHICH IS A NON REIMBURSABLE
MANDATE WHICH ARE ALL STATE IT
ALSO GOVERNMENT AGENCIES ARE.
ASKED TO FOOT THE BILL FOR SO
AGAIN BUT TWO TWO WITNESSES TO
SPEAK VERY QUICKLY ABOUT THE YES
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY MISTER
MEMBERS KEVIN BACON WITH
AMERICAN CIVIL LIBERTIES UNION
OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL TO ADDRESS THE
TYPOGRAPHICAL ERROR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
STRUCTURE MEMBERS JIM E. WERE
WITH A CALIFORNIA NEWS
PUBLISHERS ASSOCIATION --
ALSO IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL --
AND IT'S ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT IN
LIGHT --
THAT'D BE PASSED IN LIGHT OF THE
EFFECTIVE DATE OF AB SEVEN FORTY
EIGHT WHICH IS IN JULY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OR ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
OKAY DON'T BREAK MY EQUIPMENT
YOU HAVE YOU VERY YET RECORD
BREAKING YOU BOUGHT IT.
HOW MUCH IT COST?
A LOT.
A BAD HIGH A CALIFORNIA CIVIL
LIBERTIES ADVOCACY AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES SUPPORT ANY
WITNESSES OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE ANY QUESTIONS.
CNN YOU MAY CLOSE --
JUST RESPECT FOR US RIGHT UP.
AND CHAIR RECOMMENDS AND I AM
[inaudible]
SURPRISED.
LET TECHNICAL ERROR GET THROUGH
BUT THE TWO OKAY.
IT'S PRETTY THOROUGH MISTER TANG --
CALLED ROLLER BLADE ON THE
LAWYERS.
ON AB FIFTY FOR THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
JONES SAWYER --
JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY LACKEY
AYE BARRICADE HAND.
BAUER-KAHAN I DEEP.
DEEP I KAMLAGER-DOVE
KAMLAGER-DOVE AYE QUIRK AYE
QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO [inaudible]
WICKS.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT AB.
SIXTY ONE THANK YOU AB SIXTY ONE
IS -- A BILL
I BROUGHT FORWARD --
LAST YEAR HOPING THAT WE HAVE A
NEW ADMINISTRATION WILL TAKE A
NOTHER LOOK AT THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION.
AB SIXTY ONE EXPANDS THE TYPE OF
PEOPLE WHO CAN GET ATTAINED A
GUN VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDER --
THE GOOD BONTA STRAINING ORDER
WAS FIRST PASSED INTO LAW IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN AND THEN
ACTUALLY IMPLEMENTED IN --
TWENTY SIXTEEN AS WE'VE SEEN
THIS LET BE IMPLEMENTED WE SEEN
ITS EFFECTIVENESS I REALLY DO
NEED TO COMMANDED PARTICULAR SAN
DIEGO CITY ATTORNEY MAR ELLIOTT
WHO HAS REALLY WORKED.
HAND IN HAND WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO AGGRESSIVELY TAKE
GUNS TEMPORARILY OUT OF THE
HANDS OF INDIVIDUALS WHO
PROBABLY SHOULDN'T BE POSSESSING
THEM.
THIS LEGISLATION EXPANDS WHO CAN
ASK FOR A GUN BONTA STRAINING
ORDER FROM THE COURT TO
TEMPORARILY TAKE A GUN AWAY.
CURRENTLY THE DEFINITION FALLS
WITH FAMILY MEMBERS AS WELL AS
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THIS WOULD EXPAND IT TO PEOPLE
WHO ARE CO WORKERS EMPLOYERS AS
WELL AS PEOPLE WHO YOU GO TO
SCHOOL WITH SO ADMINISTRATORS
TEACHERS PROFESSORS.
AND THE REASON IS AS WE'VE SEEN
FAR TOO MANY SCHOOL SHOOTINGS AS
WELL AS WORKPLACE SHOOTINGS.
WE SAW ALSO IN THIS SITUATION IN
VENTURA COUNTY WE HAD ACTUALLY
LAW ENFORCEMENT INDIVIDUALS WHO
COULD HAVE TAKEN THE GUN AWAY
INTERACTED WITH THE GOVERNMENT
AND THEN.
DID NOT MOVE FORWARD WITH IT
UNFORTUNATELY --
WHAT WE DO KNOW IS THAT THE
GOVERNOR GOVERNOR BROWN HAD A
VETO MESSAGE THAT HE THOUGHT
THAT PEOPLE SHOULD WORK THROUGH
LAW ENFORCEMENT WE DON'T WE
DON'T DISAGREE WITH THAT?
BUT THIS ALLOWS PEOPLE THE
OPTION IF AFTER DISCUSSING THE
ISSUE WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT LAW
ENFORCEMENT NOT INTERESTED IN
MOVING FORWARD.
THEY HAVE A RIGHT TO GO TO COURT
TO PETITION THE COURT PETITION A
JUDGE IN AGAIN IT'S PETITIONING
A JUDGE IT'S NOT.
IT'S IT'S A VERY STANDARD
PROCESS THAT PEOPLE USE ALSO FOR
A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE RESTRAINING
ORDERS SO AGAIN.
VERY HAPPY TO SEE MORE OR MORE
PEOPLE UTILIZE THIS TOOL THE
BEEN A COUPLE HUNDRED A GUN
BONTA STRAINING ORDERS ISSUED IN
THE STATE.
OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS
AND AGAIN I THINK WE ALL FEEL --
AT NIGHT THAT THESE HAVE
FIREARMS ALL WITNESSES TO SPEAK.
AND WOULD APPRECIATE APPRECIATE
THE COMMITTEE'S CONSIDERATION
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
CALVIN QUICK BAY AREA STUDENT
ACTIVISTS WERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL -- SO.
AS A STUDENT I'M A STUDENT
MYSELF -- IN
HIGH SCHOOL AND BLOOM MANY
PEOPLE.
MANY STUDENTS FELLOW STUDENTS OR
CO WORKERS.
ON THE WALL NO.
SOMEONE WHO IS AT RISK SOMETIMES
BETTER THAN THEIR FAMILY --
I I KNOW THERE IS STUDENTS AT MY
SCHOOL WHO.
ARE NOT ON SPEAKING TERMS WITH
THEIR FAMILY THEY'RE NOT
CONNECTED --
YOU KNOW THIS IS IN A THERE IS
AN ISSUE OF COMMUNICATION THERE
SOMETIMES SO THESE PEOPLE.
CO WORKERS EMPLOYERS TEACHERS
SOMETIMES NO BETTER THAN A
FAMILY WHEN A PERSON IS AT RISK
WHEN THE PERSON IS SUICIDAL
PERHAPS AND THEY'RE NOT
COMMUNICATING WITH.
THEIR FAMILY.
ON THE MAJORITY OF MASS
SHOOTINGS IN IN SCHOOLS ON BURKE
PLACES.
ON THEIR COUPLE EXAMPLES THAT
I'M GOING TO HIGHLIGHT THE
PARKLAND SHOOTING OF COURSE IN
THAT INSTANCE THE SHOOTER WAS
WELL KNOWN TO TEACHERS.
OBSESSION WITH FIREARMS AND THEN
IN THE AURORA ILLINOIS A
SHOOTING THAT HAPPENED LESS THAN
TWO WEEKS AGO --
IT'S AND I FIND IT ON THAT.
DISCONCERTING THAT I CAN TAKE AN
EXAMPLE THAT SO WE SENT.
V. BACKGROUND CHECKS FAILED AND
WE DON'T KNOW THE EXACT
CIRCUMSTANCES LEADING UP TO THE
SHOOTING BUT THE SHOOTER HAD
PREVIOUS CRIMINAL.
RECORD.
AND YET LAW ENFORCEMENT DID NOT
ACT.
HE WAS FIRED JUST BEFORE BEFORE
THE SHOOTING.
THE EMPLOYER THAT HE HAD.
BEEN MADE THREATS EMPLOYERS CO
WORKERS KNEW THAT THERE WAS.
HE WAS IRAQ TECH INDIVIDUAL AND
SO ULTIMATELY --
WE THINK WE NEED TO BE MORE
PROACTIVE IN OUR GUN VIOLENCE
PREVENTION LAWS AND SO WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR PRIVATE.
THANK YOU YES.
AMANDA WILCOX ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTERS OF THE BRADY
CAMPAIGN TO PREVENT GUN VIOLENCE
AS I MENTIONED IN TESTIMONY
EARLIER TODAY 97% OF COMBINES
RESTRAINING ORDERS ISSUED FAST
FAR HAVE BEEN BY LAW ENFORCEMENT.
I ACTUALLY DO NOT EXPECT THAT TO
CHANGE MUCH BY THE TIME A
CONCERNED PERSON.
IS READY TO TAKE THIS STEP TO GO
TO COURT AND FILE A PETITION
IT'S PROBABLY RAISE TO THE LEVEL
OF EMERGENCY.
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT --
SHOULD BE CAUGHT AND IS USUALLY
CAUGHT.
HOWEVER --
THERE TIMES AS WE SAW IN
PARKLAND PERHAPS IN BORDERLINE
BAR AND GRILL AND I KNOW IT'S
ALWAYS EASY TO SECOND GUESS
THESE THINGS ON HIND SIGHT.
BUT CERTAINLY THERE ARE TIMES
WHEN LAW ENFORCEMENT MAY BE
UNRESPONSIVE TO THE CONCERN.
OR WHEN UP CONCERN PARTY MAY BE
RELUCTANT CO TO GO TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT BECAUSE OF THEIR
LEGAL STATUS. FOR EXAMPLE
UNDOCUMENTED PERSON IN THE STATE --
IN THOSE CASES I THINK IT IS
OPTION TO PETITION THE COURT.
THEMSELVES.
I UNDERSTAND THE OPPOSITION'S
ARGUMENT I CARE ABOUT TO PROCESS
THE FACT THAT GUNS CAN BE TAKEN
AWAY BEFORE HEARING --
THAT'S A LEGITIMATE CONCERN.
I WOULD LIKE TO NOTE THAT --
RGV ARE ALL LAW HAS MORE
PROTECTIONS THEM BOTH OUR
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE RESTRAINING
ORDER LAWS.
AND MENTAL HEALTH OF FIRE
PROHIBITIONS DUE TO MENTAL
ILLNESS STRICTLY THE FIFTY ONE
FIFTY LAW --
SO THERE ARE MORE PROTECTIONS
AND I WOULD SAY THE SAME COMMENT
THAT I MAY WHEN THIS BILL WAS
FIRST PASSED IN THIS IS PERSONAL
FOR ME --
THE WORST THAT HAPPENS IS
SOMEONE LOSES THEIR COME FOR
TWENTY ONE DAYS.
THE WORST THAT HAPPENS WHEN
THERE IS AN ACTION WHEN THERE
COULD HAVE BEEN AND SHOULD HAVE
BEEN IS THAT SOMEONE'S LOST
THEIR LIFE.
YOU CAN ALWAYS GIVE A COME BACK
YOU CAN GET A LIFE BACK.
I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THIS THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
OR ANY OTHER WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON DANNY CANDOR
BECAUSE OUR ON BEHALF OF THE
GIPPER'S LAW CENTER TO PREVENT
GUN VIOLENCE IN SUPPORT.
TIFFANY MATTHEWS ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
MR TURN MEMBERS SYLVIA SOLELY
SHAUN BEHALF OF LOS ANGELES CITY
ATTORNEY MIKE FUERAN STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION --
WE HAVE MORE SUPPORT
[inaudible]
FOR OPPOSITION OKAY [inaudible]
UP.
WE WERE HERE FIRST.
WE'LL FIGURE IT OUT.
IT'S SO BAD HE HAD CALIFORNIA
CIVIL LIBERTIES ADVOCACY --
I HAVE NOT PERSONALLY PREPARED A
DETAILED ANALYSIS OF THIS BILL
BUT I KNOW HOW ARE BOARD MEMBERS
FEEL ABOUT IT --
ONE MEMBER USED TO WORK FOR A
COMPUTER PROGRAM WHERE PEOPLE
COME IN AND REQUEST HEROES ALL
THE TIME.
HE STATED THAT HE FELT.
THEY WERE THEY WERE SO EASY TO
GET THAT IT WAS JUST ALMOST
GUARANTEED DEAL THAT PEOPLE.
CAN GET IT HERE --
GRANTED ON AFFIDAVIT ALONE AND
SO WITH THE COMMITTEE AND YOU
KNOW THIS DOES STAY ON A
PERSON'S RECORD OF WEALTHY AFTER
WELL BEYOND THE FACT.
SO I KNOW THAT --
THOSE ARE SOME CONCERNS
EXPRESSED BY OUR BOARD AND SO WE
ARE REGRETFULLY IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU.
YES EVERY MORNING --
LIZZY BEACON WITH A SILLY OF
CALIFORNIA UNFORTUNATELY WE ARE
ALSO RESPECTFULLY IN OPPOSITION --
YEAH I DO WANT TO COMMAND THE
THE AUTHOR'S INTENT AND THE
SPIRIT WITH WHICH HE HE BRINGS
THIS BILL CERTAINLY --
THESE TRAGEDIES THAT WE'VE SEEN
ACROSS OUR COUNTRY ARE VERY
SERIOUS AND WE NEED TO TO TAKE
ACTION -- WE
DO FEEL LIKE WE NEED TO DO THAT
WITHOUT UNNECESSARILY
COMPROMISING CIVIL LIBERTIES AND
UNFORTUNATELY WE WE DO THINK
THAT THIS BILL WOULD IT
UNDERMINE PEOPLE'S DUE PROCESS
RIGHTS -- WE
ARE NOT OPPOSED TO GUN CONTROL
MEASURES THAT THAT PROTECT
PEOPLE TO PROCESS RIGHTS AND AND
AND CIVIL RIGHTS WE ARE NOT
OPPOSED TO EVEN REMOVING GUNS
FROM PEOPLE WHO POSE A DANGER TO
THEMSELVES OR OTHERS.
PROVIDED THAT THERE IS THERE ARE
NOT NON DISCRIMINATORY CRITERIA
INVOLVED AND THAT THERE IS
SUFFICIENT REDUCTION FOR DUE
PROCESS WE DID NOT OPPOSE THE
CREATION OF THE G. VIEIRA SYSTEM
MEAN IN CALIFORNIA --
THIS BILL WOULD SIGNIFICANTLY
SIX AS A RESTRAINING ORDERS AS
WE'VE HEARD FROM --
ONE OF PROPONENTS THAT THAT SOME
PEOPLE ARE CLOSER TO THEIR CO
WORKERS THAN THEY ARE TO THE
FAMILY --
THAT IS YOUR SOME PEOPLE IT IS
NOT TRUE OF OF ALL PEOPLE THEIR
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA WITH TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF CO WORKERS.
AND UNDER THIS BILL ANY ONE OF
THOSE PEOPLE COULD SEEK AS A GUN
VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDER --
YES THERE IS A JUDGE INVOLVED
WITH THIS PROCESS INVOLVES ONE
SIDE ONE SIDE PETITIONS THE
JUDGE THE JUDGE ONLY HERE'S ONE
SIDE THEY DO NOT HEAR FROM THE
OTHER PERSON --
I'M REFERRING TO THE EX PARTY --
RESTRAINING ORDERS AND THE OTHER
PERSON NOT ONLY ARE THEY NOT
THERE THEY DON'T EVEN KNOW THAT
THIS IS TAKING PLACE THE ONLY
WAY THAT THEY FIND OUT.
IS THAT AN OFFICER SHOWS UP AT
THEIR DOOR --
TO TO CONFISCATE WEAPONS --
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO HAVE NOT
BEEN ACCUSED OF A CRIME THEY
HAVE NOT BEEN ACCUSED OF MAKING
CRIMINAL THREATS THEY'VE NOT
BEEN ACCUSED OF OF COMMITTING
VIOLENCE.
AND THEY THEY MAY NOT ACTUALLY
POSSESS ANY FARMS BUT WHEN AN
OFFICER COME TO THEIR DOOR
EXPECTING TO FIND SOMEONE WHO
MAY BE DANGEROUS AND SOMEONE
HIGH UP TO THIS IS FIREARMS WE
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT HOW THAT
ENCOUNTER --
MIGHT HAPPEN AND WHETHER THAT
MIGHT.
SO OUR CONCERN IS.
NECESSARILY WITH A PERSON.
LOSING.
THEIR THEIR FARMS FOR TWENTY ONE
DAYS IT IS ALSO ABOUT THE SEARCH
THAT MIGHT TAKE PLACE --
THAT WE FEEL LIKE.
THAT WOULD HAPPEN WITHOUT
SUFFICIENT TO PROCESS.
ARE I ALSO WANTED TO NOTE THAT
REGARDING THE SCHOOLS THIS WOULD
ALLOW I'M AN EMPLOYEE AT A
SCHOOL.
WHO HAD BEEN THERE IN THE PAST
SIX MONTHS WOULD ENCOUNTER THE
STUDENT IN THE PAST SIX MONTHS?
TO SEE CONNECTS PARTY COME
BOUNCES RUNNING ORDER THE WHOLE
PURPOSE OF A GUN FOR VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING OF AN EX PARTE ORDER
IS THE URGENCY OF THE SITUATION.
AND SO THE FACT THAT A PERSON
MIGHT NOT HAVE AND ENCOUNTERED A
STUDENT FOR SIX MONTHS SEEMS.
TO NOT BE CONSISTENT WITH THE
URGENCY OF THESE TYPES OF
RESTRAINING ORDERS.
OZ SO.
OF FOR THESE REASONS WE DO THINK
THAT THIS BILL WOULD HAVE A
DISCRIMINATORY IMPACT --
YOU KNOW IN PART BECAUSE THERE
ARE PEOPLE WHO HAVE IRRATIONAL
FEARS OF PEOPLE BASED ON THEIR
RELIGION BASED ON THEIR ON THEIR
RACE --
CERTAINLY CO WORKERS CAN HARBOR
THOSE FEARS OF OTHER COWORKERS
AND SO WE DO NOT THINK THAT THIS
IS SUFFICIENT TO PROTECT PEOPLE
SEE PROCESS RIGHT SO FOR FOR
THOSE REASONS WE ARE POST
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE.
DâN READ WITH NATIONAL RIFLE
ASSOCIATION ALSO HERE FOR C. R.
PA -- IN
OPPOSITION --
AS MY COLLEAGUE HERE FROM THE
ACLU IS POINTED OUT THAT THE DUE
PROCESS PROTECTIONS IN THE
UNDERLYING CONCEPT HERE OR JUST
INADEQUATE.
WHO WERE TALK ABOUT SOMEONE'S
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS THESE ARE
PEOPLE HAVE NOT BEEN CONVICTED
OF A CRIME ADJUDICATED MENTALLY
ILL?
AND WERE GETTING THIRD PARTY
ALLEGATIONS THAT ARE AND I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE NOT ONLY
LOOK AT THIS BILL IN THE THE
SIGNIFICANT EXPANSION OF WHO CAN
BE A REPORTER --
COLLEAGUES --
COWORKERS --
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES BUT ALSO LOOK
AT SOME OF THE OTHER BILLS THAT
ARE DEALING WITH THE SAME TOPIC
THIS YEAR THAT WE'RE GONNA
ENCOUNTER INCLUDING.
EXTENDING GBR ROSE OUT TO FIVE
YEARS -- I
BELIEVE THERE'S A BILL THAT
ELIMINATES NOTICE THESE ARE
THINGS THAT WE NEED TO CONSIDER.
WHEN WE'RE GONNA SAY SOMEONE SO
DANGEROUS THAT WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE AWAY THE RIGHTS WITHOUT A
HEARING FOR SEVERAL WEEKS --
AND NOT DO ANYTHING ELSE WE'RE
NOT OFFERING MANY MIDDLE HEALTH
TREATMENT WE'RE NOT DOING
ANYTHING ELSE TO CONTROL ANY
OTHER DANGERS BEHAVIOR THAT WE
CAN HAVE.
WE'RE JUST FOCUSING ON ON
FIREARMS RIGHT SO WE NEED TO
LOOK AT HOW WE CAN --
WORK ON CRIME CONTROL WORK ON
GETTING MENTAL HEALTH RESOURCES
OUT THERE NOT JUST.
TAKING SOMEONE'S GUNS WITHOUT
DUE PROCESS --
AND THESE ORDERS CAN BE EXTENDED
RIGHT AND SO FOR LOOKING AT
EXTENDING --
YOU COULD.
CO GO YEARS WITHOUT HAVING A
RIGHTS WITH NOT EVER GETTING A
JUDICATA MENTALLY ILL OR BEING
CONVICTED OF A CRIME --
MY COLLEAGUE HERE MENTIONED --
ABOUT THE INTERACTION POLICE
WHEN I'VE HAD CONVERSATIONS WITH
LAW ENFORCEMENT THIS IS NOT A
SINGLE OFFICER GOING OUT
KNOCKING ON YOUR DOOR AND SAYING --
CLOSER AND YOUR PHARMACIST WALK
CALL.
AND THIS COULD THIS IS NOT DE
ESCALATION THIS IS ESCALATION A
LOT OF SENSE WAS THAT SOMEONE'S
GONNA BE ROLLING UP A I HAD A
CONVERSATION LAST WEEK WITH THE
SHERIFF HE SAID IT'S A AND EVERY
TIME HE'S GONNA HAVE TO GO OUT
ON THE SO.
I THINK THOSE ARE ALL THINGS
THAT WE NEED TO CONSIDER WE
STAND IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
MAINLY ON THE DUE PROCESS AND
THE SIGNIFICANT EXPANSION
REPORTERS BUT I'M HAPPY TO HAVE
A FURTHER CONVERSATION THANK YOU.
UNDERSTAND PERCENT BRITISH
REPRESENTING GUN OWNERS
CALIFORNIA ONE ECHO THE CONCERNS
OF OF THAT HAVE BEEN STATED HERE --
IN CALIFORNIA WE ACTUALLY TREAT
PEOPLE THAT ARE ARRESTED FOR A
CRIME BETTER THAN WE DO PEOPLE
WHO SOMEONE THINKS THAT MAYBE.
THEY ARE A DANGER TO THEMSELVES
OR OTHERS WHEN YOU ARRESTED AND
TAKEN TO JAIL YOU'VE GOT TWENTY
FOUR TO FORTY EIGHT HOURS BEFORE
YOU HAVE TO GO.
AND GET AN ARRAIGNMENT SO YOU
HAVE YOUR DAY IN COURT.
QUICKLY IN THIS CASE YOU HAVE
TWENTY ONE DAYS WHERE YOU
JUSTICE IS DELAYED AND AS MARTIN
LUTHER KING SAID IN LETTERS FROM
PRISON.
JUSTICE DELAYED IS JUSTICE
DENIED.
AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT'S GOING
TO HAPPEN IN THIS SITUATION --
ONE OF THE PROPONENTS A MENTION
THAT THE WORST CASE SCENARIO IS
THAT SOMEBODY'S GUNS ARE TAKEN
AWAY -- FOR
UNIT TWENTY ONE DAYS KNOW THE
WORST CASE SCENARIO IS THAT
SOMEBODY'S GUNS ARE TAKEN AWAY
FOR TWENTY ONE DAYS AND THEY
NEEDED THEM.
IN THEIR OWN HOMES OR THEIR OWN
BUSINESSES TO PROTECT THEMSELVES
AND THEY LOSE THEIR LIVES
BECAUSE SOMEBODY FILED THIS
ORDER AND THERE IS NO JUSTICE.
SO FOR THESE REASONS WE ARE.
VERY CONCERNED WITH THIS IS
POINTED OUT.
IT ALMOST SEEMS TO WAS TO BE
DISINGENUOUS THAT YOU WOULD GO
IN AND A BRIDGE SOMEBODY'S
RIGHTS.
AND THEN YOU JUST TAKE GO OFF
AND BE FREE.
THERE'S NOTHING THAT HAPPENS
NOTHING THAT'S REQUIRED TO CHECK
TO SEE IF THEY REALLY ARE A
DANGER.
EXCEPT TWENTY ONE DAYS LATER YOU
GO TO COURT AND THERE'S A
CONVERSATION ABOUT IT.
BUT IN THAT CASE IF THEY REALLY
ARE IN DANGER THEY'RE JUST TOLD
GO OUT.
AND AS WE KNOW PEOPLE WHO --
YOU KNOW CAN GET GUNS THROUGH
ILLEGAL MEANS TO IF THEY'RE THAT
HECK BENT ON ON COMMITTING SOME
SORT OF THE VIEW.
THAT'S WHY WE'RE OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible] FIVE IN
ANY OTHER BEEN.
MARCO GEORGE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION --
I THINK WE WOULD OPPOSE THIS
BILL UNLESS AS AMENDED I WOULD
SECOND THE CONCERNS THAT --
THIS BUCHANAN EXPRESSED ABOUT
DUE PROCESS AND THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES OF A SEARCH BY
ARMED POLICE OFFICERS AT
SOMEONE'S HOME BASED ON THE EX
PARTE ORDER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MISTER QUIRK.
I'M.
SO I HAVE THIS AS AS I'VE TOLD
YOU BEFORE SEMI MEMBER ACTING I
HAVE THE SAME CONCERNS THAT THE
CIVIL RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS HAVE.
NOT QUITE THE SAME AS THE GUN
OWNERS BUT WE HAVE BEEN TO BE ON
THE SAME RARELY ARE WE EVER HAVE
SAME SIDE BUT TODAY WE ARE --
I COULD ACCEPT SOMETHING THAT
WAS MORE NARROW FOR EXAMPLE A
TEACHER --
WOULD GO TO THE PRINCIPAL AND TO
GET --
DETERMINE THAT THE STUDENT WAS
AT RISK BUT JUST TO HAVE A
RANDOM CO WORKERS SAY SOMEONE IS
AT RISK IS JUST. TOO HOW CAN I
SAY IT YOU KNOW SOMEBODY CAN BE
SETTLING THE SCORE.
THEY CAN BE LYING THROUGH THEIR
TEETH.
IT JUST DOESN'T SEEM APPROPRIATE
TO ME I THINK IT NEEDS TO BE
DONE I COULD SUPPORT THE BILL IN
A MORE NARROW WAY BUT NOT AS
IT'S CURRENTLY --
PRESENTED.
ANY OTHER QUOTE MISTER LACKEY.
YEAH JUST. TO ADD TO THIS
CONVERSATION I WOULD LIKE TO
JUST GIVE A STATISTIC THAT I
FIND TO BE FAIRLY COMPELLING.
ON THIS DISCUSSION THE FREQUENCY
TO WHICH GUN.
VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDERS WERE
ISSUED FOR TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
TO TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN
REQUESTED BY FAMILY MEMBERS WAS.
EIGHTEEN REQUESTED BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT WAS.
FIVE HUNDRED NINETY SIX SO WE
COULD SEE THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT
IS VERY VERY ACTIVE.
AND I THINK THAT --
IN ALL HONESTY THIS A SOLUTION
IN SEARCH OF A PROBLEM AND THE
ARE DUE PROCESS CONCERNS ARE
VERY VERY.
POWERFUL MY OPINION SO I I WILL
NOT BE ABLE TO SUPPORT THIS
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU I DID
JUST TO CLARIFY THE STATS --
MY AND MY COLLEAGUE FROM --
LANCASTER'S CORRECT THERE'S
ABOUT SIX HUNDRED THAT HAVE BEEN
ISSUED OVER THE THREE YEARS.
IF YOU THINK ABOUT THE MILLIONS
OF GUN OWNERS IN FROM A SMALL
NUMBER.
WHILE CERTAIN LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES HAVE BEEN ACTIVE PRIME
MANY OF THOSE LARGE MAJORITY OF
THOSE HAVE COME FROM SAN DIEGO.
BECAUSE OF THE CITY ATTORNEY'S
LEADERSHIP.
I'LL JUST GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE
FOR THE TO COUNTY THAT I
REPRESENT SAN FRANCISCO AND SAN
MATTEO.
THERE'S ONLY BEEN ONE ISSUED IN
THAT THREE YEAR PERIOD.
SO AGAIN FOR WHATEVER REASON THE
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES IN MY
TO COUNTIES.
HAVEN'T REALLY SEEN THIS AS OUR
PRIORITY HAVEN'T DONE ANYTHING
GIVEN THE WE HAVE PERSONALLY MET
WITH -- WHAT
WITH WITH ONE OF THE AGENCIES IN
OUR IN OUR JURISDICTION AGAIN IT
JUST ALLOWS INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
LIVING IN THOSE JURISDICTIONS TO
HAVE ANOTHER RECOURSE?
ON SIX HUNDRED IN THREE YEARS IS
NOT A VERY LARGE NUMBER I THINK
WHEN WHEN I FIRST PRESENTED THIS
BILL IN TWENTY SIXTEEN THE
CONCERN IS --
THIS IS GOING TO BE YOU KNOW
THERE'S GONNA BE A LINE BY THE
COURT ROOM AND THEY'LL BE
HANDING THEM OUT BY THE
THOUSANDS OF THE MILLIONS AND
REALLY.
THAT HAS NOT REALLY HAPPENED I
THINK EVEN WITH THIS --
EXPANSION.
THIS EXPANSION WILL ONLY.
MY IN MY OPINION SLIGHTLY
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF GUN
VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDERS BUT
WHAT IT DOES IT GIVES PEOPLE A
REASONABLE OPTION WHO CAN WHO
ARE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THEIR
SITUATIONS.
UNFORTUNATELY WITH MANY OF THE
ALWAYS HERE OR WHAT THE
SITUATION WAS AFTER THE FACT
WHEN I INTRODUCED THIS LAST YEAR
WE HEARD ABOUT THE PARKING
SITUATION WITH THE FBI WAS.
WATCHING THIS INDIVIDUAL THE
PRINCIPLES WATCHING THIS
INDIVIDUAL THE TEACHERS WERE
WATCHING THIS INDIVIDUAL
UNFORTUNATELY NONE OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS HAVE THE RIGHT TO DO
ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
UNDER FLORIDA LAW.
UNDER OUR LOG FIFTY AYE FISHEL
COULD DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT --
WE SIGNED INTO A AGAIN YOU HAD.
DIFFERENT GOVERNMENT AGENCIES
INCLUDING LAW ENFORCEMENT
INTERACT WITH THIS INDIVIDUAL
AND NOTHING WAS DONE.
SO AGAIN AND ALLOWS PEOPLE.
RECOURSE ALLOWS PEOPLE TO TAKE.
A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF ACTION IN
THEIR OWN HANDS WHICH I BELIEVE
IS HIS THEIR RIGHT TO PROTEST
LABOR ONE HAS A RIGHT TO GO TO
WORK AND NOT GET KILLED.
PEOPLE HAVE A RIGHT TO GO TO
SCHOOL AND NOT GET KILLED AFTER
THE PARKING SHOOTING I'M A
FOURTH GRADER I HAD A FIFTH
GRADER.
IF YOU CAN IMAGINE AS A PARENT
OF A FIFTH GRADER [inaudible]
HAVE A TEACHER HAVE TO TALK. TO
GO TO FIFTH GRADERS ABOUT WHAT
TO DO.
IN THE CASE OF AN ACTIVE SHOOTER.
OKAY THIS IS NOT A PRISON.
THIS IS NOT A JUVENILE HALL.
THIS IS NOT [inaudible]
IF A FACILITY THAT SHOULD BE
ANYWHERE [inaudible]
AT RISK.
BUT THE FACT.
THAT IT SEEMS EVERY WEEK GOES BY
WE SEEM TO HAVE SCHOOL SHOOTINGS.
AND THAT'S OUR SCHOOLS IN THIS
COUNTRY [inaudible]
AREN'T SAFE.
WHAT IS A SAY ABOUT US AS A
SOCIETY WITH THE SAME BALANCE AS
A OF THE LEGISLATURE THAT IF WE
HAVEN'T DO IF WE'RE NOT DOING
EVERYTHING POSSIBLE? TO MAKE OUR
SCHOOL CHILDREN SAFE.
I DON'T THINK WE'RE DOING OUR
JOB SO AGAIN I THINK THIS IS A
MODEST MEASURE. TO MOVE IN THAT
DIRECTION --
APPRECIATE THAT COMMITTEES
SUPPORT IN THE PAST AND AND
AGAIN BACK HERE THIS YEAR. TO
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR THE
COMMITTEE TO AGAIN --
SUPPORT AB SIXTY ONE THANK YOU
I'LL MAKE A MOTION TO MOVE THE
BELL [inaudible]
A SECOND.
OKAY.
THANK YOU AND AND I KNOW THIS IS
THIS IS --
OUT OF ECHO DOES THE SAME AS MR
QUIRK BAD --
YOU'VE PROBABLY DONE SOMETHING
THAT THEY CAN'T DO A WASHING DC
IS GET THE ACLU IN IT AND ARE A
ON THE SAME PAGE IN A AN HAVE
MEETS COLLEGE OTHER COLLEAGUES
IS A PRETTY REMARKABLE.
FEAT IN ITSELF --
I'M SUPPORTING THE BILL AND
HOPEFULLY YOU TAKE SOME OF THE
COMMENTS GOT MR QUIRK ON THE
OTHER SIDE.
IF THE ECONOMIC COME UP WITH
SOME COMPROMISE YOU MAY EVEN BE
ABLE TO WORK WITH THE ACLU. TO
TRY TO GET SOME TYPE OF
COMPROMISE BY I DON'T WANT TO
DIE HERE WANT TO MOVE FORWARD.
AND SO I'M RECOMMENDING AN AYE
VOTE.
RED COROLLA.
ON AB SIXTY ONE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS JONES SAWYER JONES SAWYER
AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY NO BARRICADE HAN HI
BAUER-KAHAN I DEEP.
NO DEEP NOW KAMLAGER-DOVE.
I'M GOING ABSTAINED [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE ABSTAINED.
QUIRK NO QUIRK NOW SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I WICKS I WICKS I THAT
MEASURE.
FAILED.
SO I WHAT'S FOR RECONSIDERATION.
IF THERE'S NO OBJECTION --
TO DO A BY UNANIMOUS CONSENT
[inaudible]
EXISTING.
AND WHAT DO THE ADD ONS.
LACKEY ON THE RULES [inaudible]
ON CONSENT.
SANTIAGO ON THE RULES.
SANTIAGO I'D WICKS ON THE RULES
I ON CONSENT.
WICKS I ITEM NUMBER ONE AB
THIRTY TWO WICKS [inaudible]
WICKS I ITEM NUMBER TWO A BE
FORTY FIVE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I ITEM NUMBER THREE AB
FIFTY FOUR SANTIAGO SANTIAGO
WICKS.
WICKS I ITEM NUMBER FOR HAS BEEN
DISPENSED WITH ITEM NUMBER FIVE
WAS ON CONSENT.
ITEM OR SIX WAS TESTIMONY ONLY
ITEM NUMBER.
SEVEN AB ONE SIXTY FIVE SANTIAGO
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO I ITEM NUMBER EIGHT WAS
ON CONSENT ITEM NINE WAS ON
CONSENT.
ITEM TEN WAS ON CONSENT.
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN AB TWO TWO
SEVEN SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I'D WICKS WICKS I I THE
NUMBER TWELVE HAS BEEN DISPENSED
WITH.
THIS INCLUDES THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE MEETING.
STAND ADJOURNED.
A BUNCH OF DOLLARS INTERACTION I
WANT.
THIS IS A LOT OF BOB
[inaudible]
YEAH